I think it's working now
oh yay
let's see
oh
I wanted to make sure
um let me see the one key okay
okay all right
if you wanna you have anything you want
to say to the people
nothing
hello people
this is the man the myth of Legend
blessing
like share subscribe
how many likes should we 1 000 likes one
thousand likes
oh my gosh okay thank you blessing uh
what did you send me oh you sent me
everything you didn't send me any
furniture
that room is empty
okay all right okay see you bye
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
thanks YouTube channel
oh shoot I don't think I'm allowed to
put whales in the title
and beautiful
majestic creatures
okay
what up guys
welcome to the Jess pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome
oh no
freaking I think I need a third set of
headphones
freaking what are these guys
oh I do I do I can just plug it in there
though
I'll tell Auntie to come in
Auntie Jenny
let me call her
okay well what should I react to today
hey come in my room
the chat one the chat wanted to say hi
come in my room
okay what up guys welcome to the just
Harley things YouTube channel and
welcomes
to Pearl reacts you know to some
beautiful majestic creatures
and
feminazis
you know what it is
um
welcome Auntie Jenny feel free to grab
grab that chair or this chair or one
from the hallway
welcome to the stream you're not live
are you I am live
you got me online yeah
okay
I was gonna you know what you wanna
watch some whales
here we have some whale sightings I was
going to show you
sorry sorry beautiful majestic creatures
we're not supposed to say that word
okay
okay let's see
let's see
um
okay
shoot uh
somewhere in the corner see that all
right so these are the fought top five
amazing
this is the top five amazing whale
sightings I know it's a fantasy blubber
but not like that no look it no but wow
isn't that crazy
I've seen people like that on the beach
don't go into the ocean
wow
look
at least they're fit whales
I really didn't expect that yeah I
wonder if the sound is
the truly majestic creatures they really
are truly majestic creatures I don't
know you can't hear the sound on the
video can you
freaking no there's always a tech
shoe in here where's blessing when you
need them
freaking
this is the sound everybody's calling oh
wait I was like Hey buddies
press this button turn up the volume on
the keyboard
I'm clicking the volume button
blessing help me
visual keyboard America
yeah okay
is that bad yeah do something I can't
help you can't be an American
foreign
These are nice whale sightings though
aren't they
yeah no bikinis also in customs either
not very often you see a bear well
go ahead and turn up the volume on the
keyboard going to take over your
computer
the last thing is sometimes we'll take
my computer over at home okay he's gonna
fix it
that's all we need our lives for
I said solve problems yeah
I don't know how he does it but
apparently he can just like take over my
keyboard it's cool pretty much
what was your favorite moment from the
shows that you've been on
we'll make it full screen while we're
waiting what was your favorite for all
the shows yeah
or the wife School
from the beginning on that the first
show ever went on
I did enjoy that that was an eye-opener
for me because I never expected anything
like that like now I really like that
you know there are dumb women out there
but yeah
okay blessing
give me five minutes
I guess we'll have to entertain the
people for five minutes let's read the
chat so yeah I enjoyed that I enjoyed
the first one I went on
but you know I don't enjoy it at all
yeah
but I said I enjoy the first one but you
know really I don't really enjoy all of
it but yeah the first one the first one
was good that was so funny oh my God
that was so funny I was so afraid I did
not feel like telling you I was like I
have to tell this woman she's left over
today I was like I didn't know who you
were so I was like I don't know what
size yeah it was just like oh feel free
to grab a chair sit sit down so I just
thought stupid people on the show okay
then what I'll do is that I'll turn up
and see what they're saying because I
thought whatever you as young people are
talking about if you don't like that
shirt there's one in the hallway too oh
no I just can't be honestly moving on
too well for that I'll just see her
there's no point because I'm never gonna
look tall compared to use Lots I might
as well sit on below
if I get a chance
go back there so they can see you
get behind me no no see there's like a
girl
there's a gap
[Music]
and he thinks I should retire my rap
career
I think you're just getting started
I
I see him as a country almost a guitar
girl oh yeah definitely but she you know
what I'm saying she she's a little you
know wait it's so Gabby Gabby I wanted
to show you what we were watching we
don't have sound right now yes um you're
perfect what they say that women would
tell them in any crap that they want to
have
yeah
we're looking at whale sightings the
sound isn't working but
I know what about if you can hear what
they're saying they know what they're
saying where's my Ramen Coke
what do you think of this whale hold on
can I whisper something in the air yeah
yeah
she's okay
she said they look thinner than the ones
that attack well I said at least not
wearing any bikinis their their
proportions are a little better and
their fits
whale siding she said oh come on and
show you some Wheels I was an expert
what girls trying to start controversy
what that's just like oh Majestic
creature everyone's talking about you
know honestly I think I I feel like I
should give them an apology I'm sorry
Wales in the sea
I didn't mean to compare you to someone
with so much blubber
there's no sound is there I'm not
looking at yourself talking yeah it's um
oh I need to get a third set of
headphones it's okay
I normally I used to look with my own
it's just for my DJ Jays no I didn't
that came in and realized that they had
because you always walk with your own
headphones everyday name knows that what
fit on Mike yeah would you wear them
around like this and so and I just found
yeah but you need it these are like a
special kind and I've got special kind
[Laughter]
oh my gosh look how big this look at
this smells like a vagina I was good
[Laughter]
oh my
God that's why I took up twice oh my
gosh it looks like one of the um see
what else do you eat a lot
I mean they clearly eat a lot
oh my God can you imagine being right
there
see the oil's gonna swallow man
think about it
is that a man running away from a well
yeah see something's never changed
[Laughter]
I'm a double entenderous yeah
on this topic because I'm not because
I'm slim I got no excess on me I'm a
thick Queen yep so what can I say it's
nice to see a nudie will is that nudity
how much how much weight do we need to
lose auntie I need to lose like 40.
I'm not drinking anymore
how long tell her how long you've been
without it um almost two weeks now 13
days
13 days
we're gonna go for um three months
and no alcohol experience just eat water
I eat pretty clean I eat pretty clean I
just drink a lot
oh my God I was drinking heavily
every drink but yeah I think it's harder
than you say yourself to drink if you
socialize a lot it just means even
alcoholic literally yeah no I don't
drink alone no I never do that's what I
mean yeah because people say oh I'm a
social Drinker and then how often do you
go out and social start every night you
know
oh my gosh you see this one
oh my watch this
you never said we'll do a bully belly
wow that's so close have you ever seen a
belly flop die for I will I did a belly
flop one time off a high dive on
accident it was really painful see I
mean it says oh wow were you well with
no I was like six three and like like
110 pounds wow wow that was a that was a
grasshopper and you need to start all
that creamy all that Italian food as
well if you're cooking oh I don't cook
Italian I don't never cook Italian food
okay
like I grew up eating that so much I
just can't I don't eat it any
but those stretch marks sorry
well you have to ask I think what are
they called the mounts underneath the
world's belly on this switch marks
sure there's another turn but we can go
with them
yeah what did Katt Williams Say
stretch marks mean you either or small
and got big or big and got small either
way we [__]
[Laughter]
hahaha
but man that's what it looks like
look at that whale on the beach
so it's like everyone always comes after
me and says I'm too harsh but I'm just
wailing wailing a little harsh I don't I
don't support itself
and they will say no you don't really
mean something else what have you ever
heard me individually call someone a
whale if they didn't insult me first
never never I I but two wrongs to make a
right I will say okay
I just feel like okay so tell me gabby
Gabby someone comes up and hits you are
you gonna hit back
well you're asking someone who's
absolutely crazy
[Music]
I'm clicking it
or
oh let me go on the other Wi-Fi because
we're on the other side of the house
um she's really watching well
and look what it says a will save my
life you know I was watching
yeah
midi setup
a year in the life of will
can you right click with his Mac mini
speakers
okay right right click on that one use
use this for some output
then do do it for the one in the top one
of the
one of the do that again
use this for sound output yeah
okay all right so you know where the
books are
how your books are below the screen
yeah
there's an audio thing that you're
hiding right
you remember the volume that you have to
turn like
like
oh [__] okay
and then I'll try it let's see
why is a rap song no I don't hear it
oh and since it's not covered last night
these young girls yeah it's a shortage
for sure this is so dead compared to
Heights
it's Thursday wait guys hold on hold on
what left side on the left side this one
yeah
oh my God damn I went to this club
you just told me there's enough
[Music]
don't decide okay
yeah there's like a loop on the side
there right there
um
[Music]
I don't see it
it's right at the front door
there's a cord on the side I just see a
quarter in the first yeah
is
here right now
yeah it's like super loud hi guys
[Music]
um Gabby will you grab one more of these
from the just unplug one
babe I'll get your Uber honey are you
sure yeah I don't care
this
is like share subscribe like share
subscribe okay thank you how did it go
today
that was a suit
Blended looking nice
one day one day it's gonna look too big
isn't it
okay just checking
just enjoy it
okay bye
look at that oh my gosh
freaking sorry guys this is painful
majestic creatures
can I come on the show please oh thank
you whatever
okay what should we actually react to
guys let me know in the chat what you'd
like us to react to and I think that
we've already been in
is going again
yes
okay you turned on your mic volume can
you can you turn it up
that was the festival and now you turned
down oh okay yeah so you guys should be
able to hear yourself in the headphones
okay I will help me put them on
did you turn it off um I turned it up
yeah is that better we clear ourselves
now yeah
is
yeah what should we react to Blessings
what's that ever and preach oh
what's Jack TV
he wants you some sick stuff you know
blessing watches some sexy yeah the
reaction is a
God a person I couldn't sleep with
another woman oh I see
oh it's like a cheaters one okay we can
watch this this sounds we like the juicy
tea yeah
which is there a good one we should do
there's a loyalty test there
um
enjoy any of those ones are good they're
good okay I worry about you blessing but
thank you
okay
let's see if she cheats on her military
boyfriend
he's in the military and it gives you
lots of time off
so what you want yeah should we watch
this one or no yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
let's make sure the audio is working
okay
um
Pearl's learning the stream where are we
okay I knew how to stream it's just we
have this new equipment and I don't know
how to use it we're gonna watch the
freaking um loyalty test Gabby see
freaking
freaking good
there you go thank you darling let me
know if you can hear it
today can you hear the audio yes
his wife kalari it's an epic loyalty
taste um I was supposed to report to my
duty station before this but I told him
I smash or pass hold on go back family
emergency
busy husband material auntie
military boy pass
no because if I didn't know him and if I
didn't know he's in the military you
know I've always found everyone's
unattractive I just don't like his hair
I mean I know I wanted to talk but look
at it you wouldn't say I want clean
shaving military haircut I have a
boyfriend everyone's ugly
you can't say oh I don't need a new
outfit now so I want to walk down the
road I'm never going to look at another
dress in the shop
I'm in a relationship everything's ugly
everyone's
ugly do you window shopping oh yeah oh
you're always playing man not to the
museum too and women I don't
discriminate if you're good looking also
excuse me man but you look really nice
they tell me I'm after you and if I can
do it to a woman I can do it to men
nothing wrong in that telling someone
they're handsome mm-hmm
we flew all the way out here just to do
this
wow just to do this oh the military
man's the nice one he's the oh that's
okay do you guys think it's wrong to do
your partner in one of these tests yeah
yeah you think that's right you should
just dump them that's her forget the
evidence so just don't don't set them up
just dump them it's like when um people
will they'll pay like an Instagram model
to DM their boyfriend yeah
haircut
I thought he was I thought he was too I
just realized I've seen him before he
was the one that when the two women I
don't have a reaction to that I think we
did
the military man looks good
he looks like a look at the hair come on
okay yeah see I want to check it out man
and oh video's not loud enough
that's a blessing
increase the reaction it just goes to
show right that you and don't know
nothing because she thought that was she
she didn't care about the hair she was
just like military I mean he's not
military Gabby
I want to find out if this is so loud
though
I was like can we turn it down on the
freaking
and the freaking
potty I said freaking it's not like not
a freaking
isn't that not freaking freaking it's
it's good I didn't say it that far it's
just throw it in Disguise isn't it yeah
but that's good it's like classier I
think
um did you really say that freaking life
blessing now it's so loud in our
headphones
oh my God
all right that's what I was looking for
oh I can't even switch this
to him or not so I had my boy T to hit
on kalari ask alarm to leave Hannah and
then take her on a date what's up Jack
TV and welcome back to a new video
hopefully you guys are ready for this
video because I put a lot no turn down
the headphones
not the video volume
blessing what
turn down the headphones not the video
okay turn down the headphones
not the video volume
this video has a crazy ending
okay Chad is this sound okay
um
oh my God blessing yeah you know
oh
yeah
okay I told you to train me blessing I
was halfway there
yeah
turn it down that's too low I can't hear
my voice
yeah so you you this is your knob this
is your knob okay okay
let's go back to Jack TV
okay yeah so man I basically just got
back from Afghanistan man um thank you
about 16 months now I'm back and I just
really wanna
I guess like to make sure my wife's
still loyal man that's that's the most
important part to me
you win it for a rude awakening and
[__] him back on
look at them
[Music]
um
so we're here at the airport my boy just
texted me he said he arrived you feel me
so we waiting on him to pull up and [__]
like that are we gonna get [__] started
I'm really excited for this today's test
because he's actually flying in okay
you don't like
this new age style like hip-hop you're
like a proper man
it's a man's man's mom do you like
tattoos on a guy
once I can't see them as long as you can
same as women
what about what about jewelry if you
like guys that wear jewelry or depends
how much it is and what it is if it's
sentimental yeah one ring or two yeah
big old thick chains and watches and
stuff I want to go out of a man and
don't feel like you know he's gonna get
robbed
and no I don't want to film I have a go
TV
and we finally made a job you got your
whole uniform on
[Music]
I have to admit bro I'm a little nervous
about using tea for today's video bro
cause he just you know he plays around a
little bit too much but if he pulls this
off make sure you go subscribe to his
channel and then you make me put it in
my pants you ain't playing [__] in your
pants
put the damn hot chips up bro [__] I
need you in character bro we haven't ate
today you see what I'm saying he's not
focused that's why I don't want to use
him as a decoy today I know how you be
when you listen are you here you got it
you're good
laughs
hey waiting for a rude awakening [__]
him so we're gonna start phase one when
we get tired location and [__] but um
you hungry or something
good all right it's go time y'all
why did the Epic Center opening the
suitcase when the suitcase got as if
there's hardly even thinking it did not
see the extending bit it was unzipped
and I thought why because when it's
you'd have it puffy in it he I know he's
going to be a strong military man but it
just looks like he just had the
underwear in there
what's going on man
there's always someone searching for a
new job for various reasons and thanks
to had not we knew kalari was one of
those people Collard was looking for a
new job according to Hannah and I knew
this would be a perfect opportunity for
us to get killaria to show up to the
studio especially if we gave her a
guaranteed interview so is there
anything that you want to you know
stress the tea that you do and do not
want to go on through the test I mean
like if she ain't you know going for
anything that you trying to you know
throw her away don't force yourself you
feel me like don't try to touch her if
she ain't even flirting with you back
you know what I mean if that's the case
like I'm trying to bring it out of here
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah
if you trying to bring it out of there
some of it's coming out then keep going
but if she's like no like no no no no
then don't try to like well come here
like you know yeah I don't want you to
be like that but um yeah
I don't think she's gonna go for it
anyway but we're gonna test it out yeah
you know she's gonna go she's tall oh
that poor man
all right for some of you guys who
probably May recognize had not from one
of my previous videos that I did on Lex
yeah he was in his pranks we actually do
know each other we was both in the
military together yeah so man I
basically just got back from Afghanistan
man um Long Good Tour I had out there
about 16 months now I'm back and I just
really wanna
I guess like just make sure my wife's
still loyal man that's that's the most
that's his wife wow he's married they
all are in the military that's true what
did they do they they turn like 18 and
they yup get married and they drop down
on one yeah they're like pop a baby in
them don't matter if they've been dead
in three months two months one month
marriage
girl I don't know yeah
um I had one worst decision they don't
have my life they don't have the best
reputation they hardly see them
all right
we enjoy them when they're there when
you're not there well you don't know you
don't worry about women worry about
stuff that they cannot see or don't know
they're going feelings I feel he's doing
this
I don't care sometimes you're feeling
this right though I don't care
okay but like what made you put put on
this test well honestly I saw you I saw
you doing these uh videos and I was just
like man I really want to try and test
test her out and see like if she have
been loyal because I mean the people
that you've been doing I don't think
they they their boyfriends is gone for
as long as I have been and so I feel
like when a woman misses her spouse for
so long like no he said wife and women
say that he's not she's probably gonna
be vulnerable to do something so I knew
I could count on you to like try to get
this done and I want to see like what's
going to happen man I don't I don't know
I'm kind of nervous so you can do this
in the first place I'm gonna be honest
like any man would you know what I'm
saying
yeah you know if she happens to fail the
test would you still be willing to work
out your relationship or you think you
just gonna focus on your career
well honestly I think it really is going
to depend on when it's happening at that
time like how I'm feeling right then and
there like if she's like he's not
leaving
I bet you these days
what are you doing
she's licking the air
sure and I feel like she's pretty much
easy and she'll do this to any man all
right um she'll do this with any man but
if she's like barely flirting like
barely giving in
man I don't know man I a lot of people
you think you should end a relationship
over a little flirting
how much is a little you could smile at
somebody depends who you're talking
about and she makes any promises for
stuff that she can't keep yeah dump her
what about what about like if you felt
like you she was too friendly with him
there's nothing wrong to be a friendly
yeah but like maybe a little touchy No
don't touch yeah no touching supplements
I don't know about this I probably
maybe counseling I might just leave it
bro I don't know how it's like I said
just depending on how I feel at that
moment man like you know I love this
girl so it'll hurt me to like see her
like engage with another man bro like
for real tea she at the door she at the
door
tea
this [__] huh T she at the door
foreign
come on in here
you smell really good I don't know if
that's you know regulated but I just
have to tell you I speak my mind a lot
um
you thirsty anything a job interview
what is she wearing to a job that's what
I'm saying like that is wow what job is
this let's start off like a porn video
okay I'm gonna give you this application
to fill out first you said some water
yes okay I'll be right back with you
here you go
no problem
so you you live around here you got here
pretty fast yeah I stayed close some
from okay my name uh Ernest I was trying
to say what's your name again oh okay
for sure for sure that's a pretty name I
ain't never heard no name like that
um
go over your application make sure
everything's good uh
okay okay uh you left out um you know
single divorce America trying to see
what there's about you know maybe it is
comfortable
you're here
[Laughter]
thank you
look she explained it she's explaining
why she's
said she's single right now
uh
I'm a single mother oh you're a single
mother
okay how old are your kids they're uh
two and five okay you said uh single
right yes okay for sure that's not true
right there
um
happy stage they they've been being bad
and everything like that
yeah sure for sure I mean you passed it
now on with one of them you know one of
them is five years I would say YouTube
you want to raise here
yeah
I was uh well I was really born
it's not an interview can you uh give me
some more information about the position
oh okay we just need basically we just
need um people to do paperwork and stuff
like that something that um I can send
your application that you did before so
I mean it said you did you've been doing
it for like two years
like two years two three years yeah it's
like trying to make [__] up he's like
yeah
so yeah paperwork
working at this counseling foreign
I've done an interview before and I
didn't know how to run it either I was
like I don't know what questions to ask
I felt so bad for this girl because I
was like
yeah I don't even know what to ask
uh it was in the Houston area oh okay
okay for sure for sure you liked it
is that what military future was look
like though because she just looks hard
on top of the street compared to him
I'm sorry she just looks a bit rough ah
I know she's got more tattoos down there
around look at her hair you know
the clothes that don't say a military
work to me
or do the military people look a bit of
rough
yeah I mean it's would you say that
military people are a bit rough
um
we should make a military wife
I mean why do a lot of people go into
the military at such a young age because
they don't know what else to do with
their life so yeah I would say yeah yeah
a little rough
yeah it was great honestly it was great
I'm just looking for growth oh okay so
so you so you you left from there for
girls yeah you feel like you uh you'll
stay here for a long a long time uh
depending on the environment yeah now we
have a a damn good environment for sure
yeah
I'm really looking for something that's
flexible
okay yeah for sure I mean we probably
can work around it but uh we do need
some somebody like that's full time if
you if that's uh something that you can
do if you can do full time and we you
know we have a lot of people that we've
been you know interviewing and stuff
like that and everybody want to do
full-time so I want to make sure that
you can do full time so I can put you in
that same category if you look for
people in airports on a position for
sure that we do you know provide uh
Child Care here we have it with big
firms so we do provide child care so
yeah that's perfect yeah for sure you
didn't write your emergency contact down
uh we I ran right through that I don't
even know who he's talking about the
single stuff I I got caught up in this
music they're saying she's an actor in
the chat
she's an actor that's what they're
saying in the chat is she really
apparently she was on another gold
digger video so it's fake then
allegedly well
we're gonna watch it anyway I think
you're saying and stuff like that so you
write your emergency contact now for me
okay for sure
okay
um yeah I am I am the you know the
generation that we in you know how
females is they I mean God is the same
way but how girl how girls is you know
what I mean no I don't know yeah I love
harder so it's easier for y'all to
find somebody else to love real fast
you feel me
what makes you say that I mean that's
how it is I ain't never I ain't never
been in a relationship and
and or talk to somebody that didn't love
hard you feel me so that's how it is
y'all love real hard so that means
person to person not necessarily it just
depends I guess it depends on they say
the reason military gets married because
they get extra money from us and my ears
interviewing who had
she's flipping it around yeah
she's feeling him
I feel like even if she's an actor she's
feeling them anymore certain people
saying interviews Jesus interview
amazing
that's right I want to go apply for a
job and I I want to film it on chapter
and just yeah just chat [__] they'll be
like would you do your last position I'd
be like I humbled These Hoes
and then they'll be like and I'll be
like what did you do at your last
position
how long have you been saying what was
your last position
[Laughter]
why your situation so complicated and
y'all y'all not just together you feel
me
uh
he's like
overseas oh oh so you so he's in the
military yeah okay okay I mean that's
that's still the same thing if you love
them you love them
you still gotta love them
yeah
but you said it's complicated you could
have said yeah I'm I'm in a relationship
man and that'd be that I mean I just
didn't see how it related to the
position at the time yeah for sure I
appreciate it
so so
with it being complicated uh you ain't
looking for nobody right now
are you gonna drink on that okay okay I
would too but when like he come back and
forth like often on he he'd be gone a
lot are you asking a lot of questions I
mean you actually you asked about me I'm
just you know I'm trying to break the
ice with you
you feel me I understand you want to
work here and everything like that I'm
not I'm actually not the manager here my
my manager my supervisor told me to come
and do the application and do the
interview with you you know I mean so
I'm just a regular guy I'm just a
regular guy so I mean yeah you can you
can you can open up to me a little bit
it won't it won't hurt the chances of
you getting a job for sure I won't tell
them that you know we you know we
chopping it up and everything like that
okay
um
yeah this was like I said it but I'm not
gonna lie y'all because tea approach
came off very aggressive and he decided
to forget everything we rehearsed and go
off script he has race suspicion for
kalari tremendously to the point where
she actually States yeah
if T does not poisonous off of this if
this was real should he dump her yes
yeah she said she was single
ring she didn't put them that she was in
she got a ring she's not mad
she's married and she's saying she's
spoken for this different she's not
married
she said declare it you did you said I'm
not around school because I've got a
boyfriend
she's got a whole new military you know
and together she's still doing it so if
you're not allowed to look she's just
shut her mouth
right now we're gonna lose this and
everything we have done today is going
to be a complete waste
well yeah you told me it was complicated
and stuff like that and you need
somebody you know to be there for you
and like I said we have the daycare here
and if you need any anybody to be here
for you I I'll definitely be that person
for the year for you if you need it how
you doing
but I want to just you know put that out
on the table like that you know off the
rip but anything any any way shape or
form I can be there for you for sure
if you need help with the kids I can
help you you know I'm that type of man
for sure
now I see I got you blushing now
talk to me you talk to me
[Music]
it's actually been a while a minute that
I could really just sit down and just
talk to somebody okay just about all
like you know the stresses of life kids
and stuff
like I said I can help you with
everything you need uh help with and
stuff like that so I'm here I can get I
can get your contact if you if you feel
comfortable giving me your contact I
mean I see it right here on paper I can
take it if I wanted it but I feel more
comfortable with you just you know
giving it to me so if if that's cool
with you I can get your number
what you say your number was
her um modern women everybody
modern women
I don't care if they got two of your
kids if they found a better option
they're going gone military man she's
dumping for him we have a question so is
he just coming back from overseas like
this is his become especially for this
year yeah so he came home for this and
before he even sees his wife and kids
he's gonna go do he's gonna test her I
don't think it's real yeah
there's no way
um
hello
k-a-l-a-r-i okay okay for sure he's most
definitely walked in
um
so uh that I have your number I mean I
know I know everything that you got
going on you say it's complicated
um your man ain't gonna your complicated
situation yeah he ain't gonna
um you know do anything but I want to
text you anytime and then he you know he
said and you
it's um actually he's really not
in the picture like that oh okay it's
perfect
okay okay so uh so you say you ain't
gonna he ain't gonna he ain't gonna trip
about it
he's crying he kind of looks like um
money bag yo without all the tattoos and
a little more please tell me he's not
crying because I can't bury it I can't
look and see him correct he is crying
he's crying yeah you see what's here he
said he loves the rain so that's his
baby
Gabby said they missed you on the
channel they said welcome back oh
I'm flattered
so what's making you emotional right now
oh because I put my art into this dog I
need that
for sure
hey can we get somebody to get him some
napkins man
I just realized something when men cried
they really cry oh yeah
when women cry it's so fake like they
had to guess on the show and she was all
emotional oh
my God I was watching myself you know I
thought everybody kicks are saying it's
really harsh I thought let me show some
compassion you know because I don't want
that to look with all their makeup so I
thought let me just leave no because not
women are like they always try and like
do the eyes you know they never actually
like me with all that damn Botox we had
I could not touch she was crying to be
honest
your forehead
other than my currency sessions we're
gonna have a box of tissue you want
tissues well I bet I think she was
expecting me to feel bad and I'm like
you've dated like three toxic men in a
row she must have just had a badge never
made me feel bad because you fake cried
for real she seemed like a sweetheart I
think that women only really cry like
when they're alone or when they lose
money no I feel like I feel like when
they assure him if they shoot him breaks
the majority of the time like okay
because if you stop giving women
attention they'll stop crying and so
it's like the only real tears are when
women are alone like if none of us were
looking at her she would stop crying I
cry out of anger me too it makes me a
lot of frustration
yeah like if I ever find during a
volleyball game it's because I'm no
again no I know exactly what because I
don't cry like when you're sad it's like
you only cry when you're sad when you're
alone yeah but it's like
during again like I don't know yeah like
I'm just not gonna cry like when I when
I'm gonna say that don't fight crime
watch shows because you're not gonna get
no sympathy from now on actually don't
cry full stop because I don't know
don't cry no crying someone throw
spraying security
get this
emotional wreck out of here she's gotta
go yeah she's gotta go absolutely not in
my the tissues from her no it's just you
know how disappointed I was and I look
at that poor man he's actually got real
tears
women
modern women
modern women and I know it's really cool
aren't you a modern woman it's like okay
yeah but I didn't do that [__]
I mean I can't do this
you can't believe all the stuff what is
he breaking something
yeah you know I mean this we're gonna
smash something up if they're angry
oh okay
this girl from my family I can't believe
I sacrificed everything I did for man
every freaking thing I did man I'm going
there with a with a with a good head I
want you going in there you know what
I'm saying I know you mad right now but
I don't want you to do nothing that you
don't regret
something that you always said they got
guns in America
but I'm not gonna see why they wouldn't
let me have a gun license in England
I believe in guns I feel like everyone
should have gone okay I think believe in
guns if you haven't got the temperament
for them
I think that and I definitely I got the
built for prison so you've got a boat
all women shouldn't have guns only men
women are too emotional so they get
emotions
I know I look at him no no you can see
like never throw somebody else to go
wild I think it's like it's very
attractive when a guy is into shooting
because I just feel like he can protect
me and if someone tries to break into
the house he'll shoot their head off
like one of these whales I was thinking
that if they pissed me off if I felt
pissed them off they might shoot me
because that's what I'd do
now if they're in your house you're on
um what do they call it
you have an advantage because you know
your way around your house now look at
that man that shot that woman for the
bathroom door
definitely
huh any claimed yeah she went shot in
the toilet and he reckons
he was he shot her for the bathroom why
that's enough because he's an idiot
someone in the chat wouldn't know I
don't think he got off of it
yeah she shot she I think he was he was
an athlete or something didn't he she
ran into the bathroom and he shot for
the bathroom door oh my gosh did you see
the freaking
I don't know sorry that's such a country
thing to say isn't it the
at least sorry
the
case of the girl whose husband drove her
and her family off the cliff and she's
sticking by him
he tried to kill the whole family oh and
then the wife said yeah yeah
she doesn't want charges pressed yeah I
was like girl I mean listen at that
point press
loyalty but he tried to kill the whole
family
now the worst thing about it he's only
saying that because the type of family
he's not got I understand where he's
coming from
[Laughter]
do you understand think about it all
depends your type of family
but you're not hanging out with them
after they try to kill you listen right
if somebody tried to kill my family I'll
be celebrating with them mate
your kids
because it was like it was a it was his
um
it was her husband and their two kids
maybe he doesn't like them have you ever
thought about that
yeah but you shouldn't try to kill him
he just knew she was she was gonna feel
sorry for me let him off
well forgiveness
I'm good man
I said that's an L take on you what does
that mean like like a bad take L Auntie
take I didn't know my family so I don't
really care
thanks
I got your phone number do you put your
Instagram
[Music]
what do you mean what am I doing there I
just got back and this is how you this
what you doing man you telling this man
you're not even supposed to be here like
you're supposed to be in Afghanistan
right but we got this cameras man I mean
I'm not worrying about all that man I'm
not even concerned with all that I'm
concerned with the fact that you telling
this man stuff that ain't even true man
so you're a single mom are you a single
mom yeah I'm a single mom how long have
you been gone
I like how she just flips it on him no
but the acting is really bad it was
really bad it's really really bad
back like what is this what really is
this so look calorie is your name
calorie we put you on a test today to
see who's taking your lawyer T you know
what I'm saying he has some concerns
about him being gone and you're not
responding to his text messages
that's irrelevant
[Music]
so like he heard you the whole time he
was always over there and he heard your
conversation and things of that Nation
looking at him
[__] he just explained it
you know what's going on that's a girl
she didn't understand what's going on
because you see how thick she is
comprehension is hard for her
I don't work for the company or anything
like that no this is real yeah I don't
work with him he came all the way from
Afghanistan just to put you to a test
and it's real
I understand man
it's real
[__] real man wait
is this where she calls him baby
but I honestly
hold on let them talk
please just talk to me I don't want to
talk man what what can we just talk
about this because you should have
talked about we should have had that we
should have had that conversation a long
time ago
with you no but I can't reach you hey
you know how you know how to reach me
any other time you know how to reach me
in the other time I'm good
why does it have to be like this because
I sat there and watched you tell this
man on the camera that to a single
parent like really I have been a single
mom though where have you been like what
did you mean
the country and Afghanistan
exciting for your freedom that's not
good enough
modern modern women want to be victims
even in this situation she's a hundred
percent in the wrong and what is she a
single mother
a single mother that's her story so
you're paying all the bills then if
you're a single mom
actually
and get to you so let me ask you this
let me ask you this when I told you what
I was going to go do and I told you they
called me on for orders why didn't you
tell me that time well I don't think I
can do this by myself why don't you tell
me that no you ain't say nothing you say
baby okay do what you have to do and
then yeah you go and tell another man
well I'm not going I'm not pretty much
the host to do that's what I'm supposed
to say I can't stop you from doing from
doing what you want to do man it's a
conversation that needs to be had and
you ain't have it with me that's what
really tore me up inside because I'm
over here you know I'm gonna receive
people telling me all the time they're
like man your girl probably got another
man already and I'm like man no I know
she no she won't she faithful she
faithful but do not get here I've been
faithful though I have been faithful oh
my lady like there's video evidence
of you not in fact being faithful
why why Liars will die on their Hill do
you know what it is you could say this
is the point a of why you're lying point
B of why you're lying there's no other
explanation point C they'll die on their
Hill
go ahead Auntie no it depends on what
your class is cheating and she must
really think it's like giving somebody a
number IG and all that ain't really
cheating until she actually gets the ACT
but it's also just about the intention
of it like yeah it's messed up I mean I
would say it's cheating because she's in
a relationship but she might not see it
as she and she might see actually being
intimate with somebody's cheeks I think
she's just interviewing I would say that
it's I would say it's unlikely that she
has not done anything with anyone in two
years if this is how she's been yeah
it's been it's been thrown around yet
you don't know you don't know these
these 304s are like you've met some of
them
that's enough I don't want to know what
they like she said
how many what's her body count you think
Gabby oh in the 50s 50s I wouldn't be
surprised if you're the only fans you
see what she said on that camera did you
see it I mean we both sat there and
watched it with our headphones in this
freaking building and he want to see
um
right here look to you that's the
building we was just in and you sat
there and told this man right here about
how you felt about me
and now you got this crazy look on your
face like you don't even care about
what's what's going on with me like you
don't I don't have no feelings it's not
even like that so what's the problem
okay what's the problem with you so why
why are you feeling I said I have not
been able to reach you you know you
don't even be sending me enough money
taking care of these kids by myself
money modern women exchange money for
loyalty I don't know what titty nipples
are showing for a closing down
interviews like that you're in teachers
with him after getting his number
that's the real question thank you what
was your attention
I say call the Samaritans I'm glad you
found them out I'm glad you introduced
yourself to it man no no I don't even
want to because I told you not to go too
far but you did what you wanted to do
[Music]
in unison
I've been still been with it that is
another level of idiocy but the thing is
he didn't say [__] he said to the guy
and she says no no no no no don't push
your girl further at no point did she
try and stop it she said so how many
lingo that is what you call a Sim the
moment he turned around and blame the
guy for doing what he was supposed to
the modern man
he's an idiot he deserves to be
heartbrokes
to dig into it to see exactly what she
was gonna do thank you
man
you said pull it out of her and that's
what I did man I I did this now it's so
bad so now he's gonna be mad at him and
so she it's like he's setting them up to
be together because like he's gonna
leave and they're gonna be like what's
with him he's just gonna screw up you
you yeah I mean of course she did but at
the same time I told you don't go too
far bro and she went for it you know
what I'm good man I'm good on all this
like I'm really good on all nothing
about you it's pretty good right now oh
give him a toilet roll he's gonna go and
cry some more
back
to get his look back
because look yeah you need to you need
to go stick his dingling in another and
another lady another woman of the night
hey Dan he needs to go and man up he
needs to spend more time in the military
Manning out that's what he needs to do
because I just can't believe that he's
blaming that man
it's like what women do when uh uh and
the Man Cheats on them that was a sweet
she's so she didn't explain she's so red
pill now am I yeah I feel like I'm like
35 40 35 I'm not ready I'm loading
it's like this
[Music]
would you agree that women are more
complicated than men
um yeah I would yeah in the short answer
yes in certain situations are men too
simple to understand women or are women
just too complex to be understood I
think that men are too simple sometimes
I think that women are too complex yeah
I agree I just don't think men ask
enough questions like I think like women
are very vulnerable like I think most
women I know like are gonna tell you
like yo this is an issue like fix this
hello hello hello and then you know I
mean what do they say what's the
statistics of divorce like 80 of women
like you know initiate divorces and then
men are like oh my God I didn't know
what happened like [__] your wife was
telling you for the past 12 years like
what she needed and you didn't do it so
is it better to be complicated or to be
simple
um I think it's better to be complicated
gives you depth better to be complicated
but in the dating sense probably better
to be simple easier to manipulate
why is it better to be complicated if
it's harder to be understood
um because when someone can understand
you they understand all those complex
parts of you and then I feel like you
get a deeper connection
yeah same here modern women take pride
in being complicated
I just spoke a lot of nothing tonight do
you mean it's always the worst when you
ask a question and you're like uh
the other girl that was talking about
here's the thing like women don't even
know what makes them happy so they'll
nagging their husband but they don't
like
no
it's like what actually would make them
happy because he'll do it and then they
won't be happy
I feel like there's more to dig into and
more layers to uncover but in the long
run might not work out but yeah women
often describe themselves as complicated
emotional even crazy do you think women
actually want to be understood yes
wouldn't that hold them to a standard
um they kind of do but they kind of
don't they want to be understood by the
guys that
they want to be understood by basically
it's complicated
that's a good answer
they want to be understood by the guys
they want to be understood by I guess
you don't think so I don't really like
it's not Computing my brain I'm not
gonna lie to you like I need like an
example like
it's kind of like turning someone on is
it easy or complicated to turn a girl on
it's no you know what because every
girl's different every girl's different
but guys it's like yeah
oh she's naked yay all you gotta do is
the robot and it just really gets me
going I'm gonna tell you we're gonna do
your little shimmy so he was saying like
they want to be understood by certain
guys okay but it's like you don't really
care if some guy you're not interested
in understands that's true no it's only
the guys you want yeah
we say like we want something but then
we just say that to make you feel like
we want something else like when our
partner is going out to get some food
out we don't want any food but as soon
as you come back you didn't get me
anything
have you ever done that oh yeah are you
kidding me or I'll be like you know what
my mom always said if I'm eating it off
your plate the calories they don't count
they'll be like yeah so I may be eating
this Fish and Rice but that potato chip
so if your plate doesn't count
yeah like oh are you gonna eat that
that's what they mean when they say
we're complicated we don't even know
what we want
that's like me when I get mad at my
boyfriend
I get mad at him and then two minutes
later I'll be like yeah I was wrong like
I'm sorry and I just made him like
apologize to me can I make you a
sandwich honey literally I'm like yeah
no you know what I'm crazy you're right
after the whole dramatic could go about
yeah
okay this is why we shouldn't vote
I'll die on this bill
I wouldn't go that far I know you
wouldn't I will
return our rights baby it is complicated
if women were easily understood wouldn't
that hold them accountable
yes yes
wouldn't that make it hard to manipulate
yes
is there any better manipulation
strategy than remaining in
unidentifiable threat you wanna know
what did you apologize for you don't
have to say if you don't want to
what do you mean they said you apologize
to your boyfriend for being crazy oh
yeah just because I'll be over dramatic
about something like with his job and
then
you know I'll be like you know what I'm
being crazy should I run for office in
2028 that's what they're saying
absolutely and I'll be like my first
I'll be like my my very first day in
office I'm taking away the women's right
to vote and I'm stepping down and the
vice president who is a male will step
up I'm gonna be competent though I
wouldn't be old what I know you've got
to check about that age thing with the
big competency level
who when you're president you're going
to bring out that old people or is this
young people you're going to say that
people under 20 or people well you have
to be 35 or and older to run for
president
it's not very small camp isn't it oh
you're saying like who would get not
many set me from 35 to what 60.
guilt tripping that always works that's
the best time to keep and use and that's
the tactic they use all the time
definitely if you understand your woman
and you understand what why she say this
is she said when I did this interview at
like the street interviews
they caught me slacking I was doing an
interview and I thought this guy was so
cute it when I did it in in Vegas and
all the comments were like pearls into
I'm like guys stop snitching
like was it that obviously
they're like she was feeling that one I
was like
hey dude she do then she can't
manipulate you but if you don't
understand why she do this [__] she dude
and she for sure gonna be able to run
circles around you manipulate you all
types of [__] you feel me especially if
you're goofy is it easier to manipulate
somebody if you can just claim that
you're crazy and you yeah oh definitely
yeah oh my God that is such a good
question yeah
wow
yeah
it's not easier to manipulate someone
else you're crazy
I feel like it's kind of like when
people he is so good at making questions
this is like oh this is making me
thinking about myself he is this he is
the best in the game when it comes I did
the collab with him when I was in Vegas
it's complicated it's literally the best
in the game when it comes to like
interview questions
like oh I'm crazy because this zodiac
sign it's you know like I was like this
my whole life like yeah definitely and I
think some people can fall for it but
it's probably on the other person and be
like all right I'm not dealing with this
person's [__] would you want to live
with or commit to someone who admits to
being crazy
no because they're not willing to change
they're just accepting that they're
crazy and I'm going to do crazy [__] so
you should accept it and why do so many
women admit to being
even crazy and think that's acceptable
behavior this is today's it's today's
Times like people are just out of their
minds nowadays so it's like it's
accepted by everybody it's glorified all
over the place with media uh music Tick
Tock internet Instagram all that that's
what they've been on it's it's so
interesting because when you think about
it girls can call themselves crazy but a
guy can't absolutely not so like if a
guy if a guy says crazy then
automatically a woman's brain goes to
like physical violence no I when I think
of a guy crazy I think of like
a dude
not even physical I think of a guy that
like won't stop texting her like
controlling oh God that's just simp
Behavior yeah yeah it ain't life you got
to think like
you gotta think like that's just them
you feel me they don't even women don't
even understand themselves sometimes
they do something don't understand why
they did this [__]
How likely are women willing to accept
men for just the way men are
not at all a woman wants you to be how
she wants you to be type [__] so why
should men accept women for just the way
that women are
I feel like when you find the right man
though you do accept him for how he is
do we we don't try to change them at all
women know the way that these men the
way that these men describing their
women
I'm surprised that anybody wants to be
of a woman full stop they might as well
just be on their own if that if I had
that view I if I was a man and that's
what I thought about women
I'll be single
that's right there's a whole group
called mgtow and then going their own
way oh yes of course
oh
girl they women like
[__] you can't you can't live with them
you can't live without them
you know he's misses his crazy at home
right he seems like he's a little office
rocker too
some guys like crazy you have a woman
just making excuses to do whatever they
feel like they want How likely are women
willing to accept men for just the way
that men are
it's rare it's very rare so why should
men accept women for just the way that
women are we shouldn't but we do who is
more shallow men or women
shallow
that's the other thing girls do
they act like they don't know what words
mean they do this all the time in my
show
are those boobs on her neck I'll be like
modern women they'll be like what is a
modern woman can we do
[__] you know what a modern woman is
are those what boobs on her neck
do you see what I'm saying yeah
what though looks you don't look on the
deeper side I hate to say it but I'm
gonna have to say women Loki they are
because men don't care what kind of car
drink women have they don't care what
kind of phone you have they don't care
where you live women they kind of do
like they care what they're like well
you're broke
High key we don't we don't tape bums
over here
you made a money like like is it good
looking is it tall it's women they women
are more gold diggers than men I would
say but it's kind of us it depends on
the context because sexually men are
known to be more shallow but
materialistically I think that men are
actually less shallow than women I think
women are much more picky physically
than men are really yeah I I don't know
if I agree with that what percent of men
would you have have sex with
hero I have a boyfriend and he's amazing
okay
zero okay
0.01 that's him you're six three right
yeah so you like a six foot and taller
roughly yeah I mean
so that's 15 of guys if a guy meets 10
girls he'll probably hook up with five
of them I agree with her so it's like we
have all these requirements of like
first two we have to like his
personality then we have to like his
look he has to be our type then he also
you know he can't be too awkward or
whatever then otherwise we're not into
it it's gonna be good in bed he's Gotta
Have a good enough job where it's like
the men are like ah fat ass good enough
like have you ever talked to guys about
who they really find attractive they're
less picky than you think like that's
true because when I talk to like my man
about girls he like things are
attractive I'll be like her what yeah
yeah okay like I'll be like that that
that is what you like no okay it's
interesting I thought of this because on
my old like with my old producer
sometimes like we would maybe talk about
I would just asking which guests he
found you know attractive or like we
just he might say like he thought a girl
was cute or something right and
um
like they're just I was just so
surprised I was like oh really but it's
like if they have one good body part
they don't see the right it depends on
their type like everyone has a type I
guess so you'd be surprised it's like
their attraction floor is a lot lower
than you would say I don't know because
I feel like personally
like
in my past I've been with guys that I
haven't found like insanely attractive
but getting to know their personality
and getting to know them I've found but
I've seen what they they were still good
looking dudes you're you're very picky
your witch isn't a bad thing then you
ask the question
um last night about if you'd have a good
looking poor man
a good looking man with money that was
bad in bed or average ugly man that was
good in bed
none of them I just like the man I have
I would take I think I agree with you
with the you know what I'm sorry I think
the looks money or loyalty I think I
would do loyalty and money
because looks fade anyways so
you know and when you turn the lights
off
oh my gosh known to be more shallow but
are they I mean you know what it is too
you know what it is too I have really
bad eyesight and I don't wear contacts
or glasses so sometimes I'm like
maybe that maybe that's what it is I
can't really see them
exactly it's blurry is he cute I'm like
if I just close this side and then this
one it doesn't work gorgeous
you know 80 it's either 70 or 80 of men
in the US are overweight
really so if he's just in shape he's
like top 20 30 guys
like on my side women are worse though I
think we're slightly fatter I agree yeah
women more shallow for so they want
attractive successful good and bad money
they want you to do what they say man
just want you to be pretty and and come
home are women more shallow because they
want too much he sounds whips right he
says that he's talking about air indoors
he's having like you know memories
or are men more shallow because they
only want one thing
men because they only want one thing
what are your thoughts on the following
expression a woman wants one man to
satisfy her every need while a man wants
every woman to satisfy his one need wow
wow that's deep I don't think that's
true Every Woman satisfies what when is
what was it when need be like sexually I
mean
but there are men that really don't
need like multiple
what's that wrong with them
it might just be blood
sure she's still living in a fairy tale
enjoy it well
no I've been with some very loyal guys I
mean that I have found out down the line
did cheat on me
it's like even if you didn't okay if
they were in put them in Tiger Woods
position where models are throwing
themselves at them every day even the
most loyal guy is gonna give in
no you know I think so
I'm not disagreeing I am
I feel that there's something that I
really know you know what I do I do
agree with that I think there are some
really good guys out there that just
don't don't need to but I think that I
mean you always what do you say like
that it's a man's uh
biology to spread his seed right to have
multiple partners I think that's fair
like that's their natural biology but I
do I do believe that they're like really
loyal I think there are some but I just
don't think it's the majority like it's
acceptable it's definitely the majority
of men if they're if they're in Tiger
Woods position they're [__]
even even a good dude like I could still
see a good dude slipping up his wife
hasn't slept with him in a month oh
that's different that's why you have to
keep your man happy fed and satisfied
[Laughter]
I'm scared to watch this I haven't seen
it I'm scared I was very intoxicated
because there's this one girl in the
show that's just two girls wouldn't stop
talking and I was bored so I just was
like oh let me just step on it right and
didn't eat that day and
before I know it you just I excuse these
mother woman
[Laughter]
I'm learning all this mother woman
rubbish right ain't working Modern Woman
there rubbish I want to see what he was
like all I have to say is
I've got a boyfriend so it doesn't count
my opinion does count now no you say I
can't say that because I have a
boyfriend I can't say because I respect
him and I value him and yeah
he's a priority to me I don't blame you
go for it girl I am yeah
[Laughter]
anyways
but yeah the first show
that's when um Do You Remember chesca
Have you seen the chesca girl yeah she
was on that show
she's a lovely girl honestly she's a
lovely girl
um
who's the lovely girl Jessica we're
talking how she was on the first show oh
yeah
yeah I wonder where she is ah yeah they
bullied her off yeah they did but she
she's so she's so sweet she really is
that's what she handles herself really
well
I was really surprised when she wouldn't
come back to be quite honest Chaska
um she didn't when she was with Sarah
she was quite rude to him
um it was vice I thought they were I did
I I'm gonna say I was rude I didn't see
it as rude I thought it was just banter
yeah well
especially when they was like oh yeah
you know you know I don't think he was I
don't think he was a fender no she was
freaking out you know what I'm talking
about when it was a three of us it was
me Sarah yeah yeah I don't I didn't see
it was all like I just saw his being a
bit
maybe it's just me I didn't see it as
being like rude to him I just thought
that's just the way she is and he just
was trying to knock some sense into it
women don't really know what they want
do you think that's true I've seen that
I saw I saw that in a video it was this
guy uh I don't know what he was upset
about or crying about but um more fans
would actually would make more money
just kind of the tone
yeah
[Music]
all I have to say is I got so irritated
because these two were talking the whole
time and I'm talking and they're still
talking they were they were bad and let
me speak it's a lot less like mentally
they'll have two rallies and then it's
over because everyone hits so hard that
you can only do so much with it yeah
women's volleyball is a lot different
and that like there's a lack of Interest
like women's basketball you're not gonna
see girls dunking every single ball
right
like you know what I'm saying so yeah
yeah I'm like I agree I agree yeah I
don't appreciate
this is a year ago I know yeah I'm so
much thinner now you see this blubber
Majestic I think it's because like hey I
wasn't aware yet I was in Orca thank you
I'm sober now
obviously better because testosterone is
a thing yeah
more emotional fun fact yeah I saw that
on this again
come on you think men are more emotional
than women
foreign
but I think it's just the point of like
we we already know men are going to be
physically more better than yeah but why
do we have to have that comparison they
may be a great player they may be a
great athlete but why can't there's also
great athletes as women why can't it be
compared to a woman why do I have to be
compared to a man that initial that
thought process is it's an insult to be
compared to a man
what you mean because she's saying like
why do I have to be compared to because
it was about um Serena Williams being no
it was about a basketball player being
compared a female basketball player
someone said she plays like LeBron
really yeah wow but that's the thing
they're taking it as an insult
like so they're like why do I have to be
compared to a man but it's like because
they're better yeah it does
thing I'd rather be compared to a guy in
basketball because they're better
that's great but there's no man like if
they said you this is such a great panel
honestly
I feel like the quality of panel was
like the guests were better before I got
big I don't want to get roasted
that's why I'd be saying all this
outlandish
because I'm like no no one's gonna watch
this
James I'd be like dope that's the best
basketball player in the world
up there no I would pick LeBron he's
better
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
completely your opinion there's yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying it's fine
it doesn't like matter yeah yeah I know
that when I was a teenager and I first
started in volleyball like I was
constantly compared to guys yeah like
initially yeah because I had a very
masculine and aggressive way of playing
as opposed to just straight tactics so
it makes sense but I did take it as a
compliment like I never had an issue
with
but like like she can talk and I can
talk so it's like sharing a mic just
wasn't gonna work it was too big a
person yeah exactly I was just like let
me just take a shot
when it came to a point where I realized
like
that's what it is like I'm a little
tired of that narrative like I want I
don't see it I don't think it's the
narrative I see women in media all the
time like I see women in like in in
online
yeah so I don't I don't see men as being
like the Pinnacle of like 80 of consumer
buying decisions are by women so we're
all like we are constantly being
marketed for women I feel like I'm just
tired of like okay like when you look at
like commercials
like you see a 10 packs commercial and
it's like damn bro like more than our
periods please you can do your whole
life on your period
again like I mentioned before Serena
Williams like that's like one of the
only athletes that you see in these
commercials like going hard and going
big and it's nice
the girl from the track was just in it
the girl from the track team was just in
it you are telling me you don't see hot
women in athletic commercials
there was one I said Steffi Graf
how is it she was the original one what
do you think I got hot girls on my shows
like we're trying to make money here
like that's the favorite thing you think
that advertisers or discrimination
against making money
they're like yes Serena come this way
here here's your short skirt
the U.S sorry I haven't Simone bile like
no she's not from track wait wait I
can't it's a mom I was just saying that
like they're like like Serena Williams
like she is so overly sexualized because
she has like a big ass and she's like a
curvy girl I still agree with that yes
100 she's overly sexual yeah because
she'll wear these tight clothes and
everyone has a problem with it but if a
girl that was stick thin wore it it's
not a problem and I and I understand now
a little more that
that when you have a certain body type
like you can't you can't dress the same
way it is more provocative but I do
think that it's like to sexualize an
athlete if that's like tennis is a very
stop and go sport so wearing it's
wearing a tighter outfit you feel more
agile and aerodynamic and that's what
you feel comfortable playing in why are
you sexualizing her but do you think
that
sometimes I think the outfits that they
give to women are to increase views like
yeah like volleyball okay like what what
reason do we have we could wear leggings
we could absolutely wear legs I
understand
but basketball shorts and if you dive
and those like I was thinking running
shorts running shorts work yeah we could
do running shorts that's that was the
original that was the original sexy pose
like it's like well women's football
women's uh women's football they wear
underwear
why yeah well because and those girls
are good they're a talented and athletic
and it's just the problem is they won't
make money yeah it's like
you'll either have to use
it if they really wanted to make money
at women's sports they would take our
clothes off and that's not a naked
volleyball that sounds really pain the
only way I could think of monetizing
women's sports is that or social media
so like influencers team drama like you
could you could absolutely make a show
at a club freaking volleyball I do think
that women's sports is go a little this
way Second Story
is getting a lot more um traction
it's uh like if you watch the LSU
Women's Basketball team they're they're
filling every Stadium like to the brim
which is really impressive it's weird it
seems like college is more popular than
100 100
that bothers me too because it's like it
doesn't focus on her skill she's insane
oh she is
absolutely
be like sexualized in a tennis match I
just saw like the word sexualized why
because I think women sexualize
ourselves
so would you say me like wearing makeup
like this am I sexualizing myself yes
just don't wait you don't wear it just
to I do wear I do I wear it no no I
don't mean that I mean there's makeup
and there's makeup there's sexy makeup
and there's everyday makeup there's
makeup to compliment your face and
there's a cat's eyes that drawer of the
money no because you know why you have
blush
oh yeah you said you told me about this
no it's because your your cheeks are
flushed when you have sex so a lot of
makeup is like mating signals to men so
it's literally sexualizing her I can
understand that and I mean like the type
of eye makeup I do right it's like the
sexy like cat eye but to me it's
just I've always I've started doing
makeup at a young age I really enjoyed
doing it you're good at it I'm good at
it yeah it's it's it was a passion of
mine I know it's very vain whatever I
used to be a painter so then I went from
painting to doing makeup and that was
kind of how I I paint my face it's just
it's just confusing to men because it's
like if you're putting out a sexy slime
it's like then they're like they're like
looking and they're like and we're like
no don't look yeah and I think it's kind
of the same thing with
you know it's hard because women's
sports it is a uniform so so like for
spandex like what are we supposed to do
but it's still confusing to God yes and
that is different because if you look at
the outfits that they wear in tennis and
beach volleyball beach volleyball the
women are wearing less and they're not
sexy
I know they're pretty sexy I don't know
they're here there's this guy
no I don't know Moana I mean like the
short outfits we normally wear like my
new clothes I just think to myself they
got fit bodies whereas if you look at
the little outfits that they wearing
tennis yeah they're not practical
they wear them they're practical they
wear them but they're not like the
original look at the uniforms from the
volleyball and look at the uniforms from
tennis the uniforms of volleyball hasn't
changed tennis has got sexier and sexier
sexier whereas
I think the women in volleyball look up
better looking bodies
I would say volleyball players are
probably some of the most attractive
athletes I think so they're attractive
but they're not like basketball
sexualized basketball and softball no
we're volleyball players are extremely
sexualized like in high school we would
have guys come to even in a junior
college
um not as much at the at the division
one level just because it's more
monitored and it's a bigger production
going on but you have guys you know
hollering at you in the stands doesn't
mean that I mean in the media
if you look at the tennis players and
how they dress and the volleyball
players doesn't really have media like
that though
they have a beach you don't think for
beaches Beach area Washington yeah it's
more about power I guess yeah they're
pretty they look fit yeah they don't
look sexy yeah they look like women with
good bodies yeah they have such good
bodies especially when they dive around
I think wow and then they were in hardly
any clothes yeah
and then you figure how much clothing
they're actually wear it's quite minute
compared to tennis players but it's like
oh that oh
that's the outfits because they're
sexual eyes then they've been grunting
that one my other thing though is I feel
like a lot of girls
like we'll complain about being
sexualized but like if it was gone
tomorrow they'd miss it why would I wear
a mini skirt and a bra top you know it's
like you got something everybody's
looking at me and they're telling me I
look sexy and that's a complaint isn't
it but nobody's making them wear it yeah
well it is different because for for
sports they do make us wear it and
actually we had girls that's like their
parents said they couldn't wear the
spandex which is reasonable like we were
12 13. and people looked at those girls
like they're so weird
because their dad was like we don't want
them to wear the spandex or the mom I
don't know why that's that's been a
uniform for years nothing's changed what
do you mean no no they used to do shorts
like a while ago I used to see them like
in Middle School we wore like basketball
shorts for volleyball that's weird yeah
because in the movement but it's like
you must look like you're playing
and you've got shorts and it affects
your plane not really for me personally
at their bum in it rather than just play
have you got that oh my gosh that when
people pulled over me but
like I'm saying like it was stigmatized
I don't want to say stigmatized but
people thought the girls that refused to
wear the spandex were weird I don't know
if you had that in your club like the
month like it was usually Muslim girls
where their family was like then again
the guys were always the Catholics if it
was for a religion you could understand
but then did they have to play that
sport
um
yeah well I go into a sport that you
know I hate when people go into
something knowing that that's what the
rules are and then you want to change it
to suit you yeah I think they just they
didn't want to change everyone else they
just wanted to make an except like they
just wanted to see if they could wear
the that's what I mean they know you
know yeah
that's true and I don't know I don't
like that I just think you know that
what you're going into you either choose
to do that sport or go and play cricket
but maybe they love that sport maybe
that's their passion they can't be their
passion because otherwise you know what
their outfit's about so play at home
with your family if it's your passion
it's not the same or go to a different
listen right they've got Sports all
around for different cultures and
different religions and that find one
that suits you so you think that don't
go and change it you think that a girl
who is
uh what do they call that when they wear
the Muslim yeah Muslim they're
completely covered that they shouldn't
be playing certain Sports because they
have to
adjust
but I don't see why we should change the
whole event yeah because it's like if we
went to um like okay I understand I
can't go there yeah and guess how I want
to be I have to respect the rules there
so when in Rome choose a sport you're
not gonna go and play cricket in little
short mini skirt and little pants and go
to India it's like okay if I went yeah
if I went to
like when we went to Abu Dhabi in like
the effort no it wasn't average I almost
moved there really when I was in the
yeah when I was in the third grade my
dad got a job offer there was supposed
to we were gonna move what that's so
crazy yeah I'm gonna go to International
School wow because you I think when you
when certain people go abroad or go to
Muslim countries sometimes they have to
adjust
so her whole point is like you're trying
to come in and like tell them how to do
it when it's like that's the
organization they built so if you don't
like it go make your own and then they
do do that they have it's not the same
it's not as competitive but what's
what's the end goal women's sports
if anything they saved you a bunch of
money they've got some Muslim
basketballs at basketball players and
I'll tell you what right these English
Muslim basketball players would give
regular female basketball players around
for their money
and they're from England and they're
[__] hot
and they do they wear the hijab and
everything but they are I've seen them
in action and they are really I just
think if I was playing on a team with a
girl who didn't want to show any skin I
wouldn't I don't care like if you're
good I don't okay no I don't care either
I don't mind you playing it but don't
want to change the rules well yeah and
if you go as long as it's not affecting
me I don't care do whatever you want no
no you don't think they can make an
exception for most no I don't feel
there's no exceptions for anybody I
don't care what it is for what reason if
you if you don't feel comfortable
wearing Spandex do whatever you want it
doesn't affect me I'll do what I'd want
to do you do what you want to do just
don't tell me I honestly think they're
like I think people they want to do it
and the people say yes and that's fine
but if they say no accept it
I actually think that it's kind of weird
that we have 12 year old 13 year old 14
year olds in Savannah I agree I actually
like I agree I honestly think it's weird
um when you think about it like I was so
comfortable doing it because we like
like I never cared but I think sometimes
the adults that sexualize these things
not children
and it don't feel sex close to the
children until adults put sex into it so
if you win that then you you're playing
these games in your shorts it won't be
nothing to you it's like that's why when
I see her walking around half naked I
always say to her because she wears less
clothes for sports and she's a sports
person she doesn't realize how short her
clothes are because that's a lot of
clothes yeah so that means I just think
that people make it sexualized yeah but
anybody who's sexualizes but the thing
is like there are predators like there
are there are like like like I just
don't think we should make it easy
but I'm saying like I just think you're
supposed to protect children and if
you're putting them in a situation where
they're playing a sports they're
interacting with oftentimes male coaches
and it's really common for male coaches
to like it's like there's always creepy
coaches at clubs like it was it was yeah
I could think of like three coaches that
got fired for weird there's one that's
still they they weren't
and so I just think like it's really not
wise to be putting these children in
like these type like I just I think that
like you should especially with young
girls
like it's not wise to be putting them in
these tiny like anybody else you're 12
years old and you're signed up with the
children in in those outfits right what
outfits they be wearing if they decide
to come become professional the same app
yeah but they're young they're young I'm
saying it's the same outfits so it's not
like you're changing a uniform just for
children they go into that sport knowing
that they would be wearing this uniform
forever and ever and ever and I think
don't chase uniform protect the kids
okay for like for example the uniform is
Society for example when I was playing
club we would have a tournament in San
Jose every year that in the convention
center would be going on at the same
time as far Khan do you know what furcon
is no so far con is basically people
that dress up in animal costumes and
they have
intercourse with a lot of they're
basically a giant orgy yeah you can look
it up it's it's crazy so where are these
like teenage girls like just like 14 13
14 15 year old girls playing volleyball
in this convention center you know we're
changing our jerseys all this stuff and
these [__] these weirdos are walking
around watching us you know they're
staying in the same Hotel you know they
literally sit there and watch our games
it was so uncomfortable to the point
where they banned them from coming to
the convention thank God but still it's
like I would have felt more comfortable
if I was covered up you know I like I
felt very uncomfortable so I think I
just that's done to protect children
that's down to the adults to protect you
and if I why wait so something happens
then to close then to stop them from
coming near you it should have been done
that from the start so somebody didn't
do their research you
didn't get here when it comes down to it
if you're gonna have a league you try to
put the kids in more clothes rather than
less clothes I think it all depends on
the sports because sometimes more
clothes won't help the sport and with
the movement and stuff and I think that
if you've got a uniform that's been
there for years and years it isn't the
uniform that's changing Society no I'm
saying like the uniform has changed over
the years they used to wear shorts like
when I was in Middle School it used to
be shorts and things I mean
professionally has it always been short
so it's always been no it's switched
over even look if you look at basketball
like the the basketball jerseys used to
be like super long and then it gets
shorter shorter shorter and then
sometimes it goes back to long it's like
style if I had the child and I did not
do uniform then I won't put them in the
school same pool if you want to protect
your child don't put my name don't put
them in that sport find one that suits
you okay I'm gonna start sexualizing
that your balls look real good yeah I'm
at home touching on that there was a
coach I can't remember where she was
from but it was breast cancer awareness
and she had on pink leather pants oh my
God that coach knew what she was doing
very coach I was so oh I don't remember
what her name was I wish I could Google
it put it in the chat guys she was fine
she was hot but I'm like girl you know
what you're
top nothing good she looked great but
someone said is this inappropriate for a
coach I'm like why is that what is it
what if I do more tight pants and you
could see stuff and like is that
inappropriate I hate to bring in races
yeah also a racial thing often times
they have always sexualized black women
and at the same time masculinize us it
makes no sense and then discriminates
again
you're gonna constantly sexualize us
like get it together dog like we are not
just I don't know
okay wait so the next the next
appreciate sorry okay I gotta I gotta
move on to the next Super Chat um okay
the average guy lasts what 10 to 15
minutes what have you heard the man you
stupid chance
uh they're on there
all right
there's a five dollar one I can't see
because they're just I need it on your
laptops yeah so you can't spare an hour
a week don't be surprised when he's I'm
not even taking any money you guys send
right now it's all being donated towards
the new soundboard four more mics hell
yeah it was
wow Pearl didn't even know
again oh my God I was so chunky that was
so chunky well it doesn't help that
you're sitting up towards the camera
yeah that angle was not not doing any
justice it's not but I was chunky then I
could have eight [__] in here
if you're entertained now imagine eight
of us maybe maybe even bring in some I
actually prefer this size I think five
is better than eight
but
it's hard to recruit for it because if
you have five and two or three girls
cancel then you're at two or three and
that's not a show and you know
um
huh if nobody turns you end up doing it
live on your ass yeah
the recruiters are starting to get it
thank you God and she needs our podcast
pop in of eight people yeah and and
fifty dollar Super Chat we're all gonna
take a shot
I was lying I didn't drink
I took plenty foreign
I'm a woman but I don't believe in
modern feminism
I'm glad what do you think of feminism
Gabby
I've got a boyfriend so it doesn't
matter to me
I think modern feminism is toxic
this guy
for example like like long distance
it's okay we can watch something else
I'm scared to see what I'm gonna say you
want to keep watching it out
just go a little harder but if it gets
crazy positive give me control it's like
maybe you're gonna talk
I don't know okay I feel like talking
for me personally that would be like no
so a year what do you think no I'm damn
lying because I've never talked to
someone for more than like two months
before cuffing it or they always cup it
usually after like it depends on the
strength of the relationship but I will
say speaking from my current
relationship her and I were actually
talking for a long time like I would say
like six months oh my gosh I forgot she
was dating a girl and she got here
oh my gosh I forgot typically I want to
date like not right away but like maybe
after a month or two like I feel like
okay listen to me when I say this listen
to me if a man likes you he will lock it
down like that if the man really wants
you he will lock it down like that I did
a poll on Twitter and I said how soon do
you know if you're gonna marry a girl
what do you think they said
don't know three months exact 36 the
majority said uh almost 60 said in the
first six months I will say this
um there's 80 said in the first year
only 20 said it takes over two years go
ahead I think that like you can know if
their potential like wifey material
within the first like week or so but it
takes time to see how they move yeah so
are they gonna stay loyal to you are
they gonna ride for you are they gonna
like
are they gonna grow with you are they
going to try to conform to what you want
a wife to be and and fit into your life
yeah be careful these girls can
change their entire personality
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding no you
haven't I'm just kidding I'm the same
I'm the I'm I'm the same we're fine
less feminism
all right what are we doing at this
point but she was willing to be patient
enough with me because I was healing
from whatever was going on in my past
relationship and she was very patient
and when I was finally ready like she
was like I want to get in a relationship
you know I asked her to be my girlfriend
and things worked modern Western women
traditional foreign women what do you
think of passport Bros
passport brought like uh trying to get a
passport to come to trying to get a
nation check to go to Asia grab one come
back oh like a mail order bride you know
it's like they go get they go to like
Brazil or they go to a different country
and like I mean dude get your Playboy
get it how you live boy
[Music]
we try our best
did it last time they broke up like two
months she's with the lovely lovely
person now
yeah they seem really happy those are
amazing they seem they seem uh like a
really great fit yeah but then we also
said that about
how shall not be named
and we did um oh I was talking about her
relationship here we just said oh you
guys seem so sweet like to her right
there and they broke up
sounds like our opinion doesn't mean
anything because it's clearly not good
we just had like a really really rough
situation yeah
bro literally she saw where she went
wrong in this situation because like it
was more so something I had a problem
with and she took responsibility gave me
a long anthropology and she sent me a
dozen roses and my favorite chocolates
and a card because she wants me to know
like she's in it for me she wants to
know that she loves me
um so knowing that she's so patient with
me and understanding and I do the same
for her like that's a really healthy
relationship and that doesn't typically
happen like most people can't
communicate so you know so what if you
did that for a year do you think you
still would have kept talking I think so
yeah with her so absolutely well anybody
else Brian not probably not no problem
her and I were already in the this
relationship back home she lives in
Maryland
it's hard to hear about other people's
relationship I don't care
is Angie coming back I don't know you
come over to her I'm taking your spot
auntie you've been promoted to the front
go me
should we watch it doesn't have to be
red pill it could be anything oh oh
let's watch top-notch idiots
also put this put you put you on your
story I'm trying to get more people to
come to my room are you trying to Mango
so I'm trying to Market it show that
we're having fun
[Laughter]
laughs
like okay look happy pearl
nice you did good buddy
top-notch idiots okay popular one
what what type of video it's they're
like prank videos they go to people in
the street and press them like like
[__]
swearing up on me like that that was
wrong with you
I see
this [__] for real and we was down
[Applause]
your boys were officially hosting our
second meet and greet Saturday July 30th
from 5 P.M to 7 P.M come out and meet us
we would love to get to know you guys
bring out the fam we're gonna have a
live DJ we're gonna have a food truck I
might just give away how much you're
gonna be a whole lot of fun if you guys
always wanted to meet us this is a
chance man because we don't do this meet
and greet all the time we do it once a
year so this is a great opportunity for
you guys to come out and take some
pictures and [__] I want to get this
lighting's fire in it oh my God how do I
get my hair to curl like that I have my
I have a tiny curling one I got you
that's so cute you guys in person today
we're back in the show again I'm gonna
go throw some fake gang signs to random
people and see how people gonna react if
I accidentally throw an actual sign and
whoever bangs don't be mad bro I'm not
doing this intentionally just probably
accidentally happened this is all meant
to be jokes let's go get it it's gonna
be a whole lot of fun I have some water
oh yeah you guys want ASMR well it might
be almost empty but you can go fill it
too
hold on hold on
throat was dry
what are you looking at
okay
where you from Earth Earth what the [__]
is Earth why are you mad at me I'm from
a gang [__] be playing that
hurts
hold on sorry I have to shout out the
lovely and wonderful King riches for
putting me on to top-notch idiots so
subscribe to him because he's sexy a
bang what's up yeah well I don't care if
you're being dug
why are you mad mad dogging me homes I
can't look problem nah I advise so I
gave me ice to look sir
you want your camera look you're on
camera
[Music]
you get shot girl no they get into some
reckless ass
[__]
oh not a big boy you about to eat them
no problem you got a problem [__] you
swearing up on me like that though
what's wrong with you
I'm telling I will beat you up you
wouldn't say anything
staring at him
calm your ass down bro
oh thank you
okay
Auntie if you're watching I could use a
cup of ice
maybe a case you know what I mean like
some dessert some ice cream she had
vegetables for dinner so she yeah she
needs sugar I need some sugar
do you see me I ate my vegetables you
did so good I did you make no guys Pearl
cooked tonight I had a bite oh bars that
[__] wasn't wasn't but I actually like
vegetables when I say like that
vegetables I actually like vegetables
she doesn't
she also hide her veggies
oh my God yeah I'm like a kid
but the carnivore lady told me they're
bad for me so I was like say less
say less telling you what you want to
hear it
[Music]
oh my God
like
[Applause]
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
what about milk hey you want to know the
broke way to do it put it in water
that's I'm telling you if you've been
down bad you know you know what I'm
talking about cereal and water so I
don't even know if I have milk right now
Auntie if you're watching go to the
store
and see if you're watching this um
they're milk
laughs
sorry guys
I just I like I like a cold this this is
cute guys put a one in the chat if me
and Gabby should stream more often and
bring over friends that we have we
absolutely have
we do talk to more than Gabby's
boyfriend auntie
and me
that would be weird if we didn't
I have Jesus I don't know about you girl
I talked to him
it's my best friend maybe
I invited Sophie tonight she said she
was busy I was like darn
we'll trap her into it don't worry
we could we could get her on we'll bring
her into it it sounds like we need to
Market this as a fun experience Pearl
will always dunk on you we need to get
like a thumbnail of us like
yeah Chris
let's make the thumbnail for Chris
because
okay what should we do should
okay hold on
wait what do I look at where's that look
at look at the cameras in there
all right Chris we got it we got a
thumbnail you know you can take one oh
yeah yeah do that wait wait do that wait
wait hold on stop I go this way
not me
action in the middle oh nice we did good
this is cold now
huh
I was hoping you'd feed it to me
romantically yeah
oh that's not good you don't like it no
no I do
he didn't get shot
bro let's go let's get out of here this
was pissed
diced up
you banging on me you need to tape bro
I want to hit you first bro do you need
the face
walk away bro walk away bro walk away
walk away
the way he's wearing his shirt talking
with his shorts I know he can fight
I know we can fight
gotta click the space bar when you want
to talk oh sorry I still got your
learning I'm new to this not true to
this
oh
you're on camera bro
why are you mad I'm not throwing real
gang signs bro why are you mad you can't
be out here
no he's he's literally had a guy's pull
straps out like strapped out and they
still do it they don't care I want to
see that video
let me ask
Mr riches
teaching Thugs and criminals
will teach you a lesson brought you home
hey hey bro look look look
I said what's up all right get
it
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
hey what's up homie what are you doing
over here
what's up my G
I'm saying what are you doing out here
my boy huh
why are you chilling over here homie
it's really watching you talk about why
I'm chilling over here what you mean why
are you getting crazy with me Doug I'm
saying though what's up oh boy like the
way you riding over here on me like oh
he banged that's how I ride sure you got
a problem with someone but why you get
married to Doug what did I say that
you're getting all mad dog hey you know
what's up man should I teach you a
lesson for that or what Mom yeah
neighborhood
that's what you're rocking with that's a
that's a crib English
it's a video
there's a camera right there my boy
[Music]
scooter get on your little scooter yeah
foreign
do you really bang though
slowly with this little dog that little
tiny dog that was a little girl dog I
don't actually let me not say nothing
about that man because he looks a little
crazy
[Music]
he has a gun I didn't even see this
the way he's sitting gear looks like I'm
gonna teach you a lesson homie
to a lesson bro you know English
you can't be sitting out here my boy
when you sit like that I'm gonna teach
you a lesson yeah
I'm gonna teach you a lesson my boy sit
back down
of a lesson oh
camera right behind that tree
or he's smoking
no my boy I'm here to teach you a list
lit
where'd it go where'd it go
I just want to take that the lead
attorney love cheating reaction with
pearl we can watch that you don't watch
that sure
not the smoke out here I don't know I
was gonna show you that
trying to teach you a lesson not to
smoke out here bro huh
bro I'm talking about
you want to like learn a lesson or some
shoes
the sliced up episode is when they get
the knife pulled out on them they get
one up on slow stuff slice that man
[Music]
chapstick
hold on
slicing this one I'm just zoomed up I
think so yeah yeah y'all trying to get
sliced up or what let me slice up
any of you
[Laughter]
okay
now they really play with their life
this is totally a bad time to travel
there's like hurricane and [__]
happening in Florida but we gotta go in
the midst of the hood of New York I mean
you freaking risk your life every day
what's yeah well now it's a problem
[Music]
TNG taking over New York
it's okay he's an alcoholic this guy
literally wakes up instead of drinking
water he drinks White
I don't know how he's in the front I
watch everybody get out of the plane I'm
like where well these guys were behind
me what happened it was AJ's fault he
was taking a [__] in the back eight hour
flight bro this one is a little better
the pilot did medium skills I give them
that right now we're gonna go check into
our hotel get a good night's sleep
tomorrow morning grind starts because
again girl don't bang you are what you
eat certified bangers
[Music]
foreign
I really like this intro I should make
mine like this you need to get a um
drone yeah show the neighborhood
this is a really good idea
you guys don't understand Pearl lives in
the match I live in a top-notch
neighborhood she lives in a penthouse in
the projects
I was walking here
there's a man right on the corner of the
street just tweaking out I was like damn
Pearl your place is so nice but
yeah the neighbors and always
I love next to a bunch of crackheads
yeah I believe in gentrification
I don't
I feel like if they want to get if they
want to get rid of the crackheads I'm
serious I'm serious I don't really
understand what gentrification is but I
heard it's like making the neighborhood
better I'm like that sounds great
and they're like then the crackheads
left to move out
what that sounds amazing crackheads are
people too yeah but they can go do
crackers with gentrification is it's
taking neighborhoods away from
people that have lived there and where
the places they can't afford and then
it's making it unaffordable so where do
people where do they go because the
value of the neighborhood goes up but
then we're then the people that were
living there they can't afford it
anymore and they move somewhere else
where
you told me the crackheads couldn't make
a better situation no I I think that the
initial I think that it is a choice you
make the decision to do to partake in in
certain lifestyle choices that lead to
addiction but active addiction I I it's
a disease like these people are not in
any frame of mind to make see my choices
or decisions my cousin was a crackhead
he died at 21 or when I was 21. I'm so
sorry to hear that New Year's yeah no
it's okay
um but like honestly I don't think it
was a disease I think it was his choices
I mean I think it's shout out Jimmy love
you but
I I'm gonna agree to disagree on that I
think um addiction is is a disease and
an epidemic and I think that um crack is
whack don't do drugs then that's all I
have to say just don't do it there's no
point
crackheads live to a hundred he did not
he lived like 30 days he was old for a
crackhead to be honest a crackhead
sometimes though they get into those
positions you ever seen them like when
they're stuck and they'll be like
Defying Gravity it's really amazing oh
my God you know
it was funny with that cousin Okay so
his name is Jimmy Jimmy lived with me
yeah shout out to me
now Jimmy
lived with me when I was a kid for I
don't know why my parents allowed me to
live with a crackhead yeah come on Mom
and Dad I don't know if that was the
wisest decision but my parents are just
very like kind people we'd always let
people live with us right and
um freaking
Jimmy
um do you know what the three strike
rule is
oh are they saying mean things about me
no I was like you gotta pay attention
Okay so you know you know what the three
strike rule is
no so it's like when you have a third
criminal offense for drugs you get
locked away for a long time that's why
you have those people like
like do you know the girl that girl that
Kim Kardashian freed yeah like that was
what happened it was like her third okay
or for I think for a lot of them that's
what it was so my cousin was on a second
strike he was always in and out of
prison all the time and
what happened to him was he would always
break into people's garages and steal
[__] to like buy money for drugs right
choices again Jimmy
so so it was on his second strike and he
got caught breaking into some or no no
he got caught with drugs on him right
damn it Jimmy yeah like the police like
searched him and he had drugs on him I
know damn it right he's like he was like
that was expensive
so I wrote my grandma for the show so he
knew that he had a court date coming up
he knew he was gonna get caught right so
he hit his head I'm just gonna freaking
swallow drugs yeah yeah I'm gonna go
break into more garages because I'm
going to jail anyway so he broke into
someone's garage funny thing was he went
to court he got off because they
illegally searched him
but he got caught for breaking into
someone's garage after does that make
sense yeah he's an idiot Jimmy you're
stupid yeah it rest in peace I love you
you did it to yourself but he was one of
my favorite cousins he was really cool
crackheads are always fun yeah they're
so fun but because they don't give a
[__] about anything no but crack I used
to write letters to him in jail he would
get a little bit yeah what the heck I
did I did he would go he would be in and
out of jail that's what people don't
know me I'm from the streets
and Jimmy told me that the crack was
actually worse and or was better in jail
like he really liked Crackdown like
apparently they get back too yeah jail
crack is good but they run out of money
because they don't have a job so if no
one's sending the money that's clean
like they kind of get clean in prison
because they can't afford the crack yeah
the guards or whoever the hell sells it
don't know I didn't ask I was a kid
right the Pearl knows this by the time
she's like nine years old I don't know
he died dear Jimmy dying when I was like
I don't know between 18 and 21 but so
like I kind of found out but here's my
point here's my point with the crackhead
stuff
he died because what happens is the
crackheads get out of prison they now
can get money or whatever and they can
buy the crack easily or whatever and
they have the same dosage they used
before but they've been kind of clean
not that clean because you know they
still get a crack here and there but
it's not the same
so that's how he died was because what
don't get a crack
they still get a crack here and there
yeah
anyways that's that's the story of my
cousin who's a crackhead and that's why
I think
that oftentimes it's choices because I
would just watch him do dumb [__] can I
say a story about my roommate that was a
crackhead I know and I feel like these
stories are gonna support my argument oh
it will okay
Okay so
500 bucks you crackhead okay now let's
get into it so when I was in junior
college I needed a roommate because
people like to just bail out of my
apartment which was in
my name and I had to pick up the rent
that was how much was the rent the rent
was like 1600 a month okay and granted I
am a junior college student I'm working
three jobs no money nothing I have
nothing to my name
um because I had used yeah anyways
so this girl moves in that I had met at
a party first rule of thumb never move
in with someone that you met at a party
but I was desperate for a roommate
things were tough times wait you met
this girl at a party and decided to move
in with her yeah
yeah I was I did not make good choices
okay um a little better now not not
great but better
so because we were being friends on
social media damn here and there I'm
like does anyone need a place to live
because I'm like I need a roommate like
the ASAP she's like I can literally move
in next week perfect you have a job yes
come take the room did you get around
the lease or no no so I'm the only one
that was on the lease right so she moves
in come to find out she has a Xanax
addiction
um so she would okay well the first
instance where I was like yeah she's a
crackhead we were coming from a concert
like a little concert in our hometown
and
we're driving down well we had to leave
because she started freaking out because
of the drug she was taking and we're
driving down the road like I wasn't
sober so my friend was driving my car
I don't hear is I just
want to try to throw herself out my car
on the freeway on the freeway on the
freeway on the freeway so I actually I
was in the back seat I lied because I
reached in front of me and grabbed her
shoulders
and I said pull over who's driving what
my other roommate at the time that's
another story because she tried to sleep
with my man well we were living together
oh wow and sent a picture of my breasts
to the football team wait what yes how
did she have a picture of your boobs she
was taking a picture changing because
she was trying to take a picture of her
tan line from beach volleyball and I'm
in the background full breasts out and
sent it in a mass message to the
football team
at my school
wow yeah anyways so
I grab her shoulders this little tiny
girl
like you have two choices
you can either get out on the side of
the road on the freeway and walk your
ass home and throw yourself in front of
a car not not my business you can do
that or you can shut up
stay your ass in the car get home and
then cry about how you want to kill
yourself because I was like I'm not
about to be held responsible for you
bugging out on the drugs you decided to
take
and throw yourself out of my car as you
should Queen thank you so we get home
and I'm like I'm not dealing with this
she's freaking out because at this point
I've already seen some stuff that she'd
been into and I'm just like all right
this is too much for me so
she ends up having a break down the
floor her friend's taking care of her
I'm like whatever the next day I'm like
you good she's like yeah I'm good I'm
like okay so then she takes a bunch of
Xanax a couple days hey did you pay any
rent at this point she she did she did
um she only lived with me for like a
month so at this point um this is a
couple days later she comes into my room
and
you took my dad
I'm like I just watched you take Force
for Xanax I just witnessed you take four
Xanax and you're so high right now that
you can't even remember that you took
for Xanax practice Yeah I think you're
Xanax crackheads do that so anyways
so
it then she ends up like robbing the
target getting prosecuted all this stuff
happens I'm like at this point like rich
white girls always Rob Target and girl
and she went to Granite Bay yo it's
always the yeah
she went to a rich High School in my
town no
this girl this girl who I won't name
Alyssa
little girl at my club and she was
always robbing Walmart and I was like
[__] but Rob somewhere nice to her
my Walmart right you're shooting so low
you're gonna do it something legal like
do something I was just like like I
remember I'm like you have your parents
a credit card why don't you just pay for
it
okay okay so
at this point volleyball starts really
taking off for me I'm like doing very
like life is just starting to go my my
way I can't I'm like I don't want to
associate with anyone like this anymore
this is too much drama she's ridiculous
she's a crackhead I can't deal with this
anymore so because I have volleyball
like I have to be up at 4am and she's
having people over
God for God knows what time oh she also
happened to start prostitution so that
was a big red flag she's on top on top
of the drug addiction so I was like
she's maybe maybe we should get you to
move out so I write her a very strongly
worded letter
and I say
excuse me blank
name and ride with cook
we don't have names here
but cook the crackhead
cook the crackhead we're not snitches
and you want to know I'll get to why I'm
so angry about this because girl okay I
write her note I say you have X amount
of time to get out you are no longer
allowed to live here whatever
I should have been smarter I should have
started locking my doors I knew I was
living with a Criminal
[Laughter]
so basically we would avoid each other
all the time right and then she the day
she moves out I'm like oh thank God it's
over I'm noticing I know that feeling
things are missing
where are my Air Max 95s that I just
bought where is all my really expensive
makeup huh this top that I got uh it's
nowhere to be found I'm not the most
neat person I have you know messy
Tendencies so I'm like oh maybe it's in
that pile of laundry in the corner
and then the day I'm walking around
campus and I see this lovely lady
wearing my clothes
where this girl wearing my clothes did
you try to fight her no I went up to her
I said where did you get that top she
said oh cook sold it to me
so basically the crap sorry to yell the
crackhead robbed me robbed me
sold my [__] and then walked out on x
amount of bills and then when I told her
I was going to take her to small claims
court mind you this is back in like the
days where I was I was you know I was I
was trying things I was I was trying
different when I first met her I tried
a specific thing
and she filmed it without my consent and
she threatened to Blackmail me and she
said she would send the video to my
coaches if I took her to small claims
court so I said you know what I worked
my ass off this is not worth it I will
just
pay it
and I ended up going to play division
one volleyball
[__]
I hope it was worth it
crackhead
laughs
good to be doing the wildest [__] last I
heard she's still crackhead so it's like
I hate it when people move out and steal
things
yeah me oh oh
that took me it took me way too long to
get that I was like yeah
oh
anyways anyways anyway
um what are they oh they want you want
to react to lead attorneys rules for
cheating sure also guys also let me know
when you want an Uber just let me I
don't want to keep you
I'll still stream
Gabby will you date a guy that's 5'4 no
no I have a boyfriend even if she didn't
she would not
um I have a boyfriend I wouldn't even
think about that
you could make a funny joke funny joke
call me
don't and I would
feel about this okay the rules for
cheating I love a man with a bald head I
I ever since I was young I've always but
don't call her but don't call me she
doesn't love it that much I don't love
it I have a boyfriend
I Only Have Eyes For My Man Point Blank
period end of story but the ball that is
nice but I do like I do like little
oh yeah
when it starts getting squeaky earlier
that's the
answer no when I was a kid like okay so
this is like before I even have like
attractions to like like men whatever
and like I just remember my friend's dad
had like was Bill with a bald head and a
beard I was like feeling things what is
this what is this feeling
what is this feeling ever since then
bald headed a beard but no beard so
you're lacking points
Lincoln I want to see what you guys have
to say
how do I feel about this
I don't even know what it means
if I'm really gonna break it down
I will say this though
should women
who are in marriages and they got these
kids should women uh be allowed to cheat
no
should men in these marriages three kids
should these men in marriages with kids
should they be allowed to cheat
yes
[Laughter]
it's just because you're a divorce
attorney
you greedy [__] you're playing
the game
he knows what he's doing
he's like that's like when they're like
high value men should cheat listen to
that girlfriend yes
uh I know women I know I know y'all are
like
I know
but
y'all
what's
Peg mean oh God think about this
because I'm being serious I'm not just
doing this whole Derek Jackson
for the man
but men should absolutely look let me do
this let me do this let's really just
break it down to see what the hell that
I'm talking about okay let us go back
let us pull up our trusty
a trusty little white board because I
got I got a school y'all on some things
what am I talking about
men should be allowed to cheat Rhonda
said what the [__] lead
I know I know I know
just not just this is gonna be hard to
do but just hear me out
hear me out
why are they saying you're green all
right
we gotta he talks so slow I'm gonna put
it on him but at one point yeah I was
losing interest sorry lead
let's do this let's say that I was let's
say that you know we lived in a land and
I was
the judge and the legislature so I got
to make the rules I'm the king
I'm the king
does anybody know why man should be able
to cheat in women not be able to cheat I
mean let's do this let's do this
Sabrina said TLA just lost my respect
way Sabrina wait wait you're judging me
and we haven't even I haven't even got
the Whiteboard out yet I'm sorry
I cannot listen to him from the size of
his forehead past the size of his
forehead I can't hear it I can't sorry
leave you you lost me with the cheating
and then listen I had to roast you a
little because that's just wrong he
let's hear him out Gabby let's hear him
out
[Laughter]
try to put it on one point yeah this is
20 Laughs
I am going I'm going to tell you what
the law of the land is if if it were up
to me this is the perfect law of the
land all right so this is the law law
on cheating all right
one women are forbidden to cheat period
period all right he should have said
that's pretty cool
now two men are forbidden to cheat
period
all right now number three
notwithstanding
number two
men can
cheat
on
their wives
under
if all of these conditions are present
let me change the women to wives and men
to husbands
all right so do you see what we're doing
speed it up women are for get to the
point lead because you're losing me he's
a long stroker I can tell
women cannot cheat husbands cannot cheat
those are the general rules but
we have an exception
number three is an exception
who me is like okay I got to see these
conditions yeah we're gonna call this
the TLA exception what is the TLA
exception what are we doing all right so
let's do it like this let's say uh this
is
one
two
and this is three now
what are they what what are the
conditions under which I allow every
single man to cheat
let's take a look
first condition
it's okay uh we'll say there's a
marriage they have to be married
all right second now guys listen just oh
let me do it
second guys and listen I'm gonna I'm
gonna hold you to it now listen guys
it's not just you just get to while out
second
the husband
has to
be hanging
a majority of the household bills okay
so he can cheat if he's paying the bills
Maybe
got to be pulling your weight
it can't be that you're gonna cheat on
your woman and you know she's paying 80
of the bills
it can't be that way
you have to be paying a majority of the
bills all right what is the majority
51 or more you got to be paying 51 or
more of the bills
now women you are not going to like this
just hang with me Carmen Carmen's like
hell no hang with me because this is the
construction of a law you can't just get
it and you gotta you gotta you got to
sit back and wait and get it all he is
the he okay no
because men like this are the reason
these little tiny men feel like they can
go cheat on their wives
you are the problem
let him finish the law fine let him
finish
we're constructing it so you're judging
it too quickly
you're judging it too I'm a woman
I love sin I'm a woman
we're crazy I used to be a feminist
I used to be a feminist
but now for that [__] Sensational
because Pearl was like why did you use
her dress like that because I started
dressing a lot more conservatively and
she goes why did you suggest like that I
said because feminism
thought it was thought that's what I was
supposed to do as a free independent
woman let's see where I'm going
now April says most is 95 I mean not
supposed to but mostly the majority I
said I said the guy has to be paying the
majority the guy has to be paying the
majority of the bills okay the majority
of the household bills so he's gonna pay
the majority of the household bills all
right ladies this is where you're not
gonna like me
I hope
I don't know a way to say this so I'm
not going to sugarcoat it
guys are gonna feel me on it
it doesn't sound good
let me preface it by saying everyone
controls their own body
men should not be forced to have sex
when they don't want to
women should not be forced to have sex
when they don't want to if you're a man
and you don't want to sleep with your
wife on
if you're a woman and you don't want to
sleep with your husband fine
man should not be out here forcing their
wives to sleep with them
you know there's a
there's a word for that oh rape all
right
that's unacceptable in this Society
thank the Lord
so we're not doing that
are you ready
this is the condition the wife
must be
capable
but unwilling
to have okay he's right
right it's a conclusions
listen I understand the the algorithm
feed him drain them
do it all over again make sure you look
all right you know don't give him too
many problems don't be annoying
men are simple
keep them happy I feel like we have a
hard time with that one
I'm working on it
but no time to start Elite I'm sorry for
what I said about your forehead listen
angry I'm sorry so we had a visceral
reaction to the cheating word it made me
sick let's let's wait let's let's finish
that with the husband I know I know okay
where
stop sleeping to you you would be
annoying that's funny okay I maybe
that's just my opinion
but like that is a very big part of a
relationship in my opinion yeah I want
to do especially to men like to men
that's like I mean to women too like
listen
my little girl can only do so much
but like what did you think was gonna
happen he's gonna yeah
this is big listen listen
now listen guys if you're a woman and
this helps you this helps you if you're
a woman if you're the guy's paying the
[__] bills he's paying the majority
of the bills
if you're a woman and you don't want to
do your part
but what if you're a woman and you
you're doing your thing he cannot cheat
this is just the exception
you hear that you hear that
listen to him because he's right the
exception and there's more
a guy has to meet all of these this is
not a A or or this is an and and God has
to meet all of these conditions before
he can cheat
all right
so it's not like just one or two things
no
all right so the wife has to be and do
you know who does this a lot shout out
to the nice scissors shout out to all of
our white sisters white women will cut a
white dude off immediately after the
wedding I mean white women cut it off
all of my white friends who have been
married over 10 years almost they don't
even get blow jobs anymore they don't
get nothing white women will cut it off
that's why I'm so loud people are like
why are you always yelling I'm like I'm
Italian
I'm spicy where is this energy
they're coming for white women
it's like that Spider-Man meme where
they're just like it's just like
pointing these directions
are we experiencing racism
oh my God this is terrible when the
first kid comes for for our white
brother that's half of them right there
by the second kid oh my oh my God by the
second kid
almost none of our white brothers are
getting ass
white women are called with it they are
cold
now I'll be honest with you
um I was married for 10 years
there are some bad things that my
ex-wife could say about me
and there are some bad things you know
one of two things that I say about her
three or four one thing that I do have
to say though is that we were made for
10 years listen what I'm saying
rain or shine
whether she was sick or healthy whether
she had a ton of energy or was tired
whether she was liking me or not feeling
me that day
in 10 years
not one time did she say no not what
damn y'all still got divorced
that [__] must have been weak
to do it like that
I mean
sorry when she was angry with it no I
talk about the woman
I was talking about the woman
in a decade
like
and you know in a decade not once
did I miss a mortgage payment
I held up my side of the deal she didn't
work
can you imagine this 10 years of your
life you're just chilling no kids we
don't have any kids oh
oh
sh Big Daddy
all that bad yeah she messed it up some
kid she'd have to oh my what were you
doing come on you should have spent a
little more out of her to be honest like
that's that's a very unfair deal to just
for some poontang like come on yeah I
would like there's no vaginas that good
not one time
was I like you know just completely you
know maybe I was like okay listen you
know I'm about to come on my peers I
can't do this but I can do that all
right I can't do this but I can do that
it was always I can do something
something
it's like I'm Gonna Leave man we can't
do anal every day like come on like be
reasonable okay okay
I'm reasonable we were both reasonable
I mean she was an [__] but like I'm
just saying like from that perspective
under what's the point guys under this
law I never would have been allowed to
cheat I didn't cheat and I would I would
have never been allowed to cheat because
I didn't I didn't meet this
qualification some of you men are
cheating on your wives and you don't
meet this qualification
I didn't meet this qualification the
wife must be capable but unwilling to
have sex with a husband under this law
under the law I'm cheating I couldn't
cheat and I didn't cheat for 10 years
all right even though I was married even
though I was paying the majority of the
household bills
but there's one other thing
there's one other thing and this is this
is why
well there's probably we could go into
it more but and I want you to notice
that it says capable it's not like the
woman got hit by a car and her leg is
broken her hip is crashing you're like
oh well you know you did it you didn't
you didn't have sex with me so now I get
to cheat because you're you know you
broke your uh
you broke your hip right I will say this
though here's another one here's another
one this is the fourth one
the husband and the wife
must have
one or more children
right
the husband or the wife must have one or
more children
guys let me tell you something
this last part
is the key
it is the key
if
if your wife is capable if you are
married
and you are paying the majority of the
household bills and your wife is capable
but unwilling to have sex with you
but you do not have any children
you are not allowed to cheat
some of you guys are like well I don't
know where are you going that's the
whole point of the karma karma doesn't
make no damn sense
this is why I see things guys I see
things that y'all don't see like y'all
are just on like the level y'all are on
the Earth
and I'm like 50 000 feet up like in a
plane and I see I've done this [__] for
20 years I see it all
I see it all why is it
why is it that
if the man and the wife if they don't
have a child why is the husband not
allowed to cheat you're not allowed to
cheat because you should get a divorce
you should get a divorce
why are you cheating
when you can get a divorce just divorce
it you're gonna be like oh well she's
gonna take half that's what you agree to
when you married her did you get a
freedom no I didn't have anything back
then well there you go
divorce our ass
if she makes you unhappy whether she's
sleeping with you or not or
disrespecting you or not or whatever
she's doing or not doing
if you are unhappy and it looks you look
down the road you're like man this is
not getting any better just divorce her
the [__] are you cheating divorce and
start living your life be free you don't
have any kids you don't have any
any why are you still in the house with
her
well I paid for the house well the judge
is not going to give you but you know
maybe I can sell it and split deck
you know he's like I know a lawyer he's
a smart guy he's a smart guy because he
baited us at the beginning he he baited
me he he led me to I was like you speak
for yourself I was not faded I was I I
was like you know that's disgusting it's
like when you're doing content this is
what you'll do
instead of saying well women tend to
play the victim in the situation modern
women want to be victims what's a bit
more entertaining that's my second one
yeah yeah
married men should cheat or well there's
certain situations where Mary met it's
like respect oh [__] respect the game
baby do what you gotta do
but what happens guys
when your wife is capable but unwilling
to have sex with you and you guys have a
Kia
and you look down the road leave you're
like man lee told me to divorce her but
now I got this kid
what happens if I divorce her I love my
kid six years old we go out and play
ball every day I get to see my kid every
single day of the year when I wake up in
the morning my kid is in this house when
I go to sleep at night my kid is in this
house what do women say all the time
women are like Oh I'm a mama bear
I'm a mama bear I'll do anything for my
kid I'll do anything for my child I'll
go to the ends of the Earth for my child
guess what
a lot of dads feel the same [__] way
you think you're gonna take my
six-year-old from me
would I do anything for my six-year-old
you think that you're going to stop
having sex
and I'm supposed to suffer for the next
30 years of my life
but to get sex I have to give up my kid
[__] you if you'll do anything for your
kid I'll do anything for mine how about
that how about that period you're
capable of having sex with me but you
don't want to fine fine
don't have sex with me
we got a kid I don't hit it anyway I've
already hit
you're walking around this [__] in
Crocs dirty cross
20 40 80 pounds overweight
if you don't wanna you don't want to
give me nothing fine
but what you're not gonna do
is find a way to force me
to divorce you over my libido and now I
lose the ability
to wake up in the same house as my child
that's messed up I'm a man
and all men are human beings
and all human beings have needs
can I go a month without sex yeah
can I go three months without sex yeah
but you want me to go six months you
want me to go to a year and then when I
ask you when I communicate with you say
hey it's been a year yeah I'm just not
really a year [__] nah a month I can't
no there's no way sorry if I'm in a
relation no way
away
Apparently one of us he's saying the
white women are doing it
which white women
to
get some ass on the side now now let me
say this too because the laws are kind
of changing there's an exception to the
exception
exception to the exception is
uh so this will be what number four
the exception to the exception is uh not
with standing be above
uh the husband is not allowed to cheat
if the wife Will consent to 50 50
custody I say Gods if your wife is like
listen
[Music]
I just don't want to have sex with you
anymore
but we can co-parent we'll get a divorce
50 50 custody now you've lost the right
to cheat
now you're back in divorce land
divorce her she'll agree to 54. when do
you think
you should be allowed
do you think it's wrong to date someone
when you're separated and unofficially
divorced
um I don't think that it's I mean I I
think that if you there's children
involved yes
I think if there's no kids involved if
you guys aren't together and you guys
aren't sleeping like you know the
relationship is done yeah I think that
that's that's a little if he says things
change so much after marriage for some
women guys
I just can't imagine well I think that
um personally
I just don't I mean I guess I just don't
really understand because if you're
already living together and you're
already paying bills together then what
would be so different when you have a
wedding and you're married you know if
you've been together for years so but if
you're just moving in together for the
first time after marriage then I can see
how that could cause such a strain but
also like I'm it's weird though the
outcomes are better for people that
didn't live together before I don't know
crazy I don't know why but I wonder if
it's because um that tends to be people
who have more of a religious background
and people with more marriages that have
a bond over God it's like they don't
believe in divorce but they they it's
like you'd have to choose your person
every day you have to choose your
partner my parents were a prime example
of that 33 years they were together and
through the good times bad times through
my dad's disease they chose each other
every single day everyone was a ride or
die she was a ride or die she went
listen
she she held it down for my for my
father through the hardest times of his
life like she was his rock you know so I
got that I'm grateful having an example
of that love is the greatest gift do you
find that dating guys that grew up in
single parent homes is like like the
same way like guys don't like have a
hard time dating girls that come from
single parent homes that it's the same
with guys 100 it's definitely a
difference there's a and that's just a
reality because a lot of times I've
never seen it like they don't know what
a healthy relationship looks exactly
like and that's not to say that they
can't learn but it's like you have to
grow with you have to help guide them
through that and all but I will say I
think you don't want to be guiding the
relationship you know what I mean it's
kind of like you want to you want to
follow you don't it depends on the type
of person you choose to lay down with
and be with right so I don't think that
it's a detriment that you're a single
you come from a single parent household
but it's how you you are willing to grow
and learn from and yeah we as women we
don't necessarily want to
teach a man how to be that but when you
if you love someone and yeah I'm not
saying there aren't exceptions I'm just
saying as a rule but I also think that
um single parents sometimes like men who
haven't had a father figure in their
life it's like two one of two ways
they're either like the most incredible
fathers because they feel like they have
to be the dad that they never had or
they have the tendency they think that
it's you know they feel like well my dad
was I just find that sometimes even the
guys that are incredible dads like
they're a bit of a simps and don't
really know like how to deal with women
like they're really good Dads but a lot
of times they get screwed over because
they don't really see red flags and
girls or know how to
that a girl
you think that's true or not I don't
know honestly it's just I'm just reading
chicken what'd you think of our reaction
we could do this on Sundays I'm super
down I'm trying to I'm having a good old
time tell people that you had fun so we
can I actually want to see if we can do
a call in but I'm not sure if this will
work blessing
I'm blessing you need to be here
full-time no bless hey like his thing is
he wants everything to be perfect
and so
what what'll happen oh I'm not sharing
the screen okay what is my login to zoom
um
but so I used to use like the
the easy way to do things but he wants
to make it all techy and I now I just
don't know how to do anything
Unleashed on me
see if this is the password I'm gonna
try to do a zoom link and just see if
this works
we can talk to people I'm not drinking
enough water
this water bottle whenever I'm actually
good about filling it you just I need to
get one honestly I've been so bad about
drinking water lately and like ever
since everything happened like I've not
been able to eat like that and which is
fine because I feel like I'm getting you
look so skinny okay well let's not go
that far
I definitely am like starting to give me
a couple months guys I'm gonna try guys
to do a zoom like I just want to see if
this works I wanted to test it today
because I've been thinking I've been
I've had monologues in my head that I
want to give and I just don't think it's
the same when I have a producer I want
to feel like it's just me and you guys I
don't like morning coffee talks yeah
like professional yeah I don't know I
just wanna I have a whole
a whole monologue I just want people to
listen to me too can I plug my social
media yeah she's she's a tick tock guys
I'm on Tick Tock but don't judge me for
my content G the scally and it is do the
Sally because I'm six three so don't
they will judge you yeah you know what
judge me I don't care as long as you're
watching
um my Instagram is gabroberts24 and I'm
starting a YouTube channel but it's
gonna be very low quality
it's not even known
um also do the stally so okay we're
gonna do two hours okay well
my current plan only allows me 40
minutes okay well broke
[Laughter]
okay save I'm just gonna I just want to
see if this works okay invite link
just want to see
if the audio picks up
just on Zoom I'll have to download Zoom
one this is a new computer
I am
I know I really should figure out how to
afford Zoom
um just tell the assistant
um oh yeah Tallulah if you're watching
get her Zoom yeah get my
[Music]
I need her number so I can like book
things for you through her no really
it's actually
um I want you know what I want to do I
just want to take you to like a tailor
and get you a custom pair of pants
like a custom pair of jeans oh my God I
need I feel like you would love that I
need to go to a tailor and just get all
of my clothes tailored because none of
them fit me right you deserve it
you deserve it lady I'm downloading Zoom
guys we're gonna see if this works
um
guys I Got 5 000 followers on
words like they'll start somewhere
uh okay for five thousand followers
though I get pretty decent you do decent
numbers you're doing well it's some good
guys you're doing well honey
okay allow
okay we're gonna see
we're gonna see if this works join with
computer audio
okay video does it work no
um
well I wonder if other people can still
I'm gonna guys I'm gonna put this in the
chat we're just gonna test it
how do I if you give them a zoom link if
it's like open they should be able to
well I just want to know if the audio
will pick it up invite link okay
okay I'm gonna go to the chat
I don't either
that's what blessings yeah that's my
blessing
I don't understand why he takes days off
he wants a life what rude
I know that's just something else I
thought you were dedicated to your job
blessing yeah
blessing
okay wait I need to get back to her also
can I make a point these are not hickeys
guys I have psoriasis
and my makeup is starting to come off of
it
paste okay all right guys try to see if
I want to see if you guys can hear me
there's the zoom link
um I feel like this is gonna happen
really quick
um
okay admit this is just a test I don't
really have a topic
okay I admitted him hello
it's connecting to audio I can't hear
you hello
hello oh my gosh I can hear him can you
guys hear him in the chat
is the audit because otherwise then I
can use this in the future
how are you
I'm good
thanks for calling in let's see
if you can hear me yeah you're cutting
up a little bit that's what a white girl
with a hickey would say
no guys I'm so serious though I mean it
I mean it and also who would give a
hickey right here like
right there
psoriasis
look at this huh
is it Steven or Stefan
oh Steven yeah it's funny because I have
a zoom call for a business meeting I
figured oh just come here for a sec nice
nice nice
look at it guys turn your turn the
cameras on we gotta we're trying to
trying to
you want cameras on and off yeah on on
say hi everyone I'm only doing this okay
let me turn off this YouTube channel
real quick
okay one sec it is open to anyone I'm
just letting everyone in this oh hello
okay how are you my bad lighting I just
got home what's good what's the job for
the interview for
uh I do network marketing and uh yeah
I'm just uh doing a second meeting with
one of my business partners so oh nice
yeah what do you Market what type
what type all types like uh
consumables mostly consumables anything
that you can buy again you know
good business see this this is what it
looks like on the screen oh cool
yeah isn't that nice this is cool isn't
that nice
am I the first caller yeah you were I'm
admitting I want to see how many people
I can admit in here
everyone turn your cameras on I'm
getting you crazy oh my gosh we are all
right this is getting really crazy I'm
booting you if you don't have your
camera on Amazon nothing weird no yeah
no oh come on don't please please don't
be in bed let's not just that could go
anywhere it's like were you ever uh when
you were younger and you'd go on that uh
oh my God that I remember that yeah some
weird things going to see oh my God
random people lots of random people we
could talk to camera's on yeah hold on
um I ever saw phallus camera's on no
weird stuff no weird stuff
yeah no I don't I don't want to use it
rename
oh okay well they should have called I
don't have to tell you
nobody probably should have gone to a
live show
like that
oh he's got a my are you okay are you a
YouTuber short short arcade
shuttle arcade uh twitch oh twitch do
you have an accent no I play fighting
games oh you have a good voice for that
he's the real deal
he's got a pop screen and everything he
has the voice for sports broadcasting
yeah can you can you tell me what the
score is on a game yeah
he looks like a sports broadcaster you
can call me Shoto Shoto
I don't
oh thanks very much appreciate it here
um I'm gonna be removing the people with
their cameras off
remove
remove I have all the power here it's
gonna remove Apple I'm sorry Apple
[Laughter]
um well oh there's a girl that wants to
come in oh I saw her oh
she she no Michelle
come back Michelle I saw you in the chat
oh my gosh
why why a lot of bad things happen to
good people I don't know couldn't tell
you so I think I can have my camera off
here but I could they'll still see me on
the screen so it'll still work
Gaston's world is coming in
okay guys I'm gonna finish my breakfast
I'll be here though oh okay okay what
no that's not how it works
you're defouring the rules get out shout
out go eat your breakfast in peace they
keep saying I had a report why are they
trying to tell you how to run your show
yeah it's like
come on men am I right
just kidding
is this thing on it is on it would be
awesome hello how are you
I'm good how you doing how you doing I'm
good
see you doing your thing I was just
jumping on here you said you wanted to
add as many people as you could I wanted
to help you out with that oh thank you
that's so kind of you oh we have another
girl Zoom has a pretty good capacity I'm
very I'm very curious myself I don't
know I just I I hope I don't have to buy
the premium version I'm all in on a
budget
a budget is crazy Miley
Miley I need you it's me hi hi I turned
the camera on turn the camera on oh
thank you hi hello you're so cute
this is strange her hair is so pretty
yeah you are stunning what's your
skincare routine drop it now yeah drop
the skin drop it down
I use Korean skincare me too snail music
it's changed my life I swear and also I
didn't realize I was putting on
like the skin care products in the wrong
order and like yeah there's so much to
it we're getting tips right now from a
professional
oh somebody left
I've never done uh Zoom from my phone
before this is kind of new
first time for everything right all
right
oh you know it's awkward
this is the people watching can see like
me removing people on the screen
you got your camera on and it's not a
weird background listen at least I know
it's coming they know it's coming it's
like report
report you know how are you hold no
singular Mouse it's so much harder to
kick people out of the studio you're
like Santa why have I been doing an
in-person Studio I could have just been
doing these live streams it's so much
safer it's so much safer and it would
save so much money seriously honestly
and then it's like crazy it's like
kicking ass faster out she wouldn't
leave you know you have to call security
here removed
she would have just kept calling back
see what it is she would have made it
Alias no no she's been I've I have
banished banished Esther as you should
know that lady she was making some real
threats I've never heard a British
person to make talk make threats like
this yeah you can't take British people
serious when they speak like that yeah I
mean she was threatening witchcraft on
me I'm like oh no no yeah
[Music]
one second
the Brit the British are coming the
British
how long did it take you to think of
that one
uh
uh I don't know when did that happen
[Laughter]
um but no so look did anybody see the
new uh Marvel movie no anybody The Flash
one
that's DC
um
no uh the Marvel movie uh the quantum
Mania movie
flashes oh that is DC
yeah it's got to go
I tried to I tried to let you just let
it go you gotta keep rolling with it
you're like it is I know I know what's
right I'm so excited this worked I can
do a whole she's independent blessing
you're fired yeah hold on I wanna I
wanna practice I'm gonna practice a
monologue okay okay go ahead lesson that
was a joke
do hoes get cold
do hoes get cold this is the real
question it's zero degrees outside and
she's out in a mini skirt and a crop top
is she cold
okay so as a former
hoe I did in fact used to get cold
um in fact in fact I did get cold but
did I care but did I care how did you
overcome those obstacles I met a man
that turned me into a classy lady I was
talking about the the cold but you know
I would just drink tequila
enough tequila you don't feel anything
yeah tequila helps tequila helps have
you guys heard of the William Wim Hof
method
no it doesn't involve tequila
[Music]
breathing exercise you just I don't know
you just like inhale and like expand
your belly and then just like empty it
out and if you just focus on your
breathing you don't feel the cold oh
I've heard okay who's who's audios
it's gonna be Zoom user Lance yeah Zoom
user you got to turn YouTube music I'm
sorry no sucking Lots you lost your
privilege yeah absolutely
we're cold-hearted we run a tight ship
that's crazy
guys
what's your favorite video from the
channel favorite stream
how'd you find me
well I've been following you for a while
now
um
going back to what didn't you have a
conversation with Kevin at some point oh
wow that's a long time yeah I was on
Kevin's show and I had like 20 like 15
20 000 Subs so that was before yeah even
I was I think I was that was like when I
first saw you
oh cool
I call myself one to be a content
creator I'm not that great though
so well I was asking because I'm trying
to get feedback and like we're trying to
plan the studio schedule the next couple
months I was like I wonder what people
like the live streams Street interviews
like what I want to do more and less of
the street interviews is really popular
I know like a lot of people like that
now I don't know if
is the UK really like do people are
really receptive to Street interviews in
the UK
it depends on the time of year it's just
been cold out that's why we haven't I've
been sending like a lot to do them
instead
[Music]
um didn't you get attacked I did I did
get whale whale attacked oh wow buy some
yeah yeah buy some fat chick you need
security I I have it now that was
smaller back then there's this other
time these people like
surrounded me too because all right is
this group of drunk dudes that kept
it's okay I was fine I left but yeah but
yeah I'm gonna get security in the
future because because people are crazy
so you're planning to do this how often
every Sunday huh
people join the zoom link maybe I don't
know I hadn't really planned it out I'm
just excited the zoom works I can do a
call-in show now
all right nice nice nice
for sure
you guys hit me
uh yeah who spoke is that Lance oh it's
me Winston oh Wednesday hello I do hear
you
oh yeah now so I'm from the UK as well
man I've had to say my favorite episode
of yours um I thought you know you on
that was it two blondes one thing with
those two girls and only fans
um was it on saskcast
it was the one when you were sitting
next to lead the tourney oh that one
yeah you made me laugh because you go to
the girls when you go when you go see a
healing it just manages to see me ran
through and you said but you've got only
fans as well so it doesn't help and I
started pissing myself laughing that's
hilarious
oh my no that was the thing like I would
when girls say they're healing like
I was like oh my God yeah the men are
right because whenever I'd ask questions
there was always a boy that had to do
with it
yeah wild yeah they they don't really
take a lot of accountability it's
actually quite funny when you when you
start seeing everything so
one thing I had to say thanks for
um you know putting King Richardson I
Jenny on your platform as well man I I
love those two and my girl great as well
thank you so much
and it's it's just funny like whatever
when they start talking yeah they're
like I expect a guy to have all these
requirements what would you say and then
they're like what do you bringing
they're like well I don't really know
it's like well I want a guy to do this I
want a guy to do that and like they just
think that guys just go out and just
earn money just to give it to women and
like it's like no no most guys aren't
like that at all you might find that
occasional Sim that's gonna just go and
just give you cash but the vast majority
of us men
is dude is dude changing
he's getting removed
I saw him walking into a closet sorry
dude
a little iffy I don't we're not I'm
sorry I was I was listening I just saw
that I was like
anyways um thank you so much for
watching I appreciate it
the yeah no worries do you guys would
you I want to do a red pill documentary
or Street interviews what would be more
interesting to you guys if I only have
time to do one
would be very interesting
so I kind of want to do in the next
three months I want to like interview
like divorce attorneys and stuff
it's like a UK one
I'm sorry I don't want to interrupt
anyone but no no no no my name is
no I just wanted to say that one of my
favorite Clips on your channel was
um that three hour interview you did
with Andrew Tate and all of those uh
all those crazy women
um
I got I got put I don't know Andrew Tate
just kept flooding my my feed on YouTube
and
that kind of brought me to your channel
it was it was like a wake-up call for me
you know I never really knew what men
wanted and I just came out of a
relationship and I was just asking all
these questions and you were
your platform like answered a lot of
them for me so I'm I'm really grateful
for the the message you're you're
bringing to men and to women I think
it's important for all of us
I thought that the Andrew Tate interview
was so helpful even me I'm in this space
I like learned stuff during that
interview I was like oh I never thought
about it from that point of view right
but it's like in I don't think I'm sorry
go ahead go ahead Winston that's because
hey do you know one he said he said some
great stuff so one thing he said is if
you want to motivate a man don't go to
him if he's playing video again say I'll
get off those videos
oh you do so many great things why do
you play those video games we could be
showing me some stuff and I said to
myself you know what that would motivate
me if my woman came to me and said it
like that that would motivate me and
Miley if you want to learn stuff about
guys
um free things
bedroom fun sandwich silence and I'm and
I guarantee triple down the silence just
don't give a guy a headache I guarantee
you if you just go to a guy and just you
know cater to our egos most guys don't
break up with women as it is anyway and
I guarantee you if you just cook for a
guy
you know at least three four times a
week he's not gonna leave you at all
ever and that you can go for you know
they take off the top 20 guys
I say you have the top 20 then below
that is about 60 of guys are like
marriageable and then 20 below that is
like unmarriageable you want to go for
that mid 60 of guys if you want to get
married
hi Doug long time no see
oh I always see Doug on his eyes on the
tackle stuff he's always in the chat
he's in everyone hi Doug
oh Doug Doug you're infamous
oh Duck's mother that's my OG
lead attorney
um do you want to tell him the
criticisms to his face hey Pearl how's
it going okay well first of all let's
get this let's get this clear
lead let's get this clear um wait hold
on we can't we can't have you ever hi
Dad
okay
yeah
good to see you my G good to see you
um good respect
it's kick out Doug Wait no that's like
damn that's cold bro
no he's still here okay just stop
talking okay it's a lead lead lead
how do you feel about about our reaction
to your content uh oh
um um I thought it was very good of
course Gabby you know jump into
conclusions without hearing the black
man out listen I didn't just jump I got
into a Lamborghini car and flew off of
the side of the cliff
but you know as intelligent women as you
are you guys listened and you came
around she'll be fair you talk
excrucially whatever the word is so slow
you talk so wow he's trying to get this
watch time he's trying to get this watch
time I'm from Georgia Georgia so listen
if a husband is gonna cheat on his wife
that's a real thing guys that's a heavy
that's a heavy uh topic I can't explain
to you this stuff in a 30 second Tick
Tock you know I know you guys are young
man but sometimes as you get older it's
like okay some stuff really needs some
explanation stuff some stuff might take
an hour
so I don't know what to tell you no
respect you you know you you lost me at
first but I was on once you got to the
the third point I was on the bandwagon
like I was riding with you so yeah I've
seen so many marriages where women just
stopped sleeping with their where the
wife stopped sleeping with her husband
and it's not something that's you know
always necessarily a conscious Choice a
lot of times it's biological you know
with women so much it's emotional
sometimes too and of course they'll
always blame the man right oh well
you're not making me happy or you're not
fulfilling some Duty or you're not doing
this or that but the guy actually is
completely powerless in it and you know
to be fair it's not something that this
woman saw when she was 23 and oh I'm
gonna get married and have two kids and
stop sleeping with my husband that's not
something that she envisioned uh and
certainly not something that the man
envisions uh people really don't know
how marriage work until they get until
they get in them so maybe somebody who's
26 may say oh I'll get married I'll
never stop sleeping with my husband
that's crazy I don't understand that and
then 10 years into their marriage
they're like oh well you know we
actually haven't had sex in a year and a
half and he's sleeping in the he's
sleeping in a separate bedroom this
person we're telling the kids that you
know he he sleeps out there because he
snores
that's really not why he sleeps out
there right man you're just deep guys
did I did I go too deep
I was like well you you say it sounds
like a personal experience I've been
handling these cases for 20 years it's
all I've been doing my entire Adult
Career respect so are white women were
worse when it comes to like sleeping
with their husbands we like stop doing
it
yeah wow
[Music]
that's stereotyping oh look at Miles not
a though not category I hate to agree
um
Caucasian household
[Laughter]
okay your secretary
nanny
the children were home the children were
home listen guys I mean a lot of you
guys y'all y'all y'all evaluate these
situations based on Theory and based on
what you think but people like me and to
be honest people like miles like we
actually see it so few of you really
find out what goes on inside of these
homes you have to be in there and miles
is like in there
way more than you guys yeah she sees it
like daily it's amazing miles can
probably write a book on some of the
[__] that she see because you know
there's always the theory and then
there's the practice like you know
there's the there's the the conceptual
ideas of how things work and then
there's the reality
and when you're living in these white
people's homes man you know shout out to
the white people but these white women
they are cold they are so cold with it
it can get it can get for real
and it's something that you know the
white men never anticipated they just
never anticipated this stuff
you see it you see blessing came to work
hired me today Pearl he heard my comment
Leslie I was kidding I have no power
over time
they know OT buddy yeah yeah we don't we
don't have over hot times I don't know
what you're talking about
oh my gosh wait
so tell us miles about your experience
being a nanny for 10 years Jesus how did
like what what what stuff did you see or
experience that maybe regular people
don't don't get to to see on a daily
basis well well first of all sir um I'm
not sure what your name is sir I like
that yeah you can just call me lead
my name is Miley uh Miley I'm sorry
miles I can't read and I know well one
of the first experiences early on I was
still a teenager I saw
multiple uh instances of the woman who
hired me cheating on her husband oh my
God like neglecting him completely and
her kids for this other guy through this
and she was not discreet about it at all
and I don't know how he didn't figure it
out sooner but what is she cheating with
uh a colleague yeah he had a Porsche
and so let me tell you something about
these damn work husbands man these work
husbands will absolutely take your wife
and that's why you make enough to let
her stay home
yeah yeah it's tough because the work
husband was at the kids birthday parties
but Dad wasn't so oh my God
you know what did he leave her to do but
I've also seen it the reverse where you
know
men were being
you know flirty with me in the
households
okay they're like hey Miley do you want
that raise
you wow It's Tricky what's the dynamic
like
the men were happy to have a nanny or
they would have wished their wives would
be doing some of the stuff that you were
doing
oh I could definitely see that they
wanted their wives to be doing my work
yeah
but yeah these I mean modern women
they're they're pushed back into the
workforce so soon and they feel like
they have to and you can see like that
they're not happy and they have all this
extra stress trying to manage careers
and home life like you you just can't do
it you can't be a good mother and pursue
a career to your fullest like it's hard
you gotta weigh out your options you
can't you can't have it all right
and
no and that's right that's what I feel
like
is the lie that's sold to women is that
you can have everything but everything
comes at a cost there's always like
because the thing is you can hire
everything out but then you have all
these random people in your home and it
kind of takes away from like it kind of
takes away from your home feeling like
home you know
exactly mom is always like feeling like
she the mom that I work for I mean she's
always feeling like she's a she's
missing out on those those firsts the
baby's only nine months now she went
back to work when he was three months so
like there's so much going on in that
first year of life and she's you know
she's missing out on it and she doesn't
want to would it be she make a lot of
money is she in like is she in a
high-powered physician
I don't know what she does I think she's
in management for some like
Hospital
service I I couldn't explain it to you I
don't this I don't know
[Music]
I get paid well so I assume they get
paid well
I want to see it yeah because if the guy
got paid well but she didn't get paid
well then she could just stay at home
with the kid
but if she had if she had a very
important job then they would not want
to lose out on that income so she would
go back to work and just hire a nanny so
logically it seems like she must have a
very important job
also to have nannies the vast majority
of households of course don't have
nannies I mean you really got to be
making strong six figures to justify
that yeah you guys are expensive
has there ever been tension how many how
many homes have you have you been in
have you nannied for
uh four four have you ever had any
tension where you show up and then the
wife looks at you and sees that you're
cute and whatever every day he says
every day
every day oh my God they try to like
tone myself down as much as I can you
know I don't have anyone to impress at
work I'm getting thrown up all all day
right but oh here I got it yeah I feel
it for sure so you felt it from the the
wife's side have you ever felt any any
type of
um
you know desires from the husband's side
where the husband's like oh okay Miley
you know what's going on they tried to
flirt with you or anything
well like this is something I have to
figure out because anytime
the dad I work for now is it just
one-on-one with me when his wife isn't
there he's super flirty he gives me
compliments extended eye contacts you
know close in proximity and
all those like warning signs is his wife
gonna see this video
gotta be careful
so wait wait wait I don't think they'd
be anywhere near yeah the choice careful
careful what's that age difference
between you and the the father in the
home
oh I don't know I haven't asked I think
they're like mid-30s
which is like actually so it's that's
your type is the you know physically is
the is the father kind of your type no
no no no no no no no do you have a nice
he's too nice okay all right guys
all right guys he's too nice right Jesus
like man are you hearing this how can
you win you could not be nice to these
women these modern women right you have
to treat them like the I don't know how
you have to treat them but not nice
apparently how is he too nice
um well I see his wife walk all over him
and plus like he has a wife so it's like
I don't I don't see him in that way I
don't know he's spoken for
[Music]
um
listen if Drake was married you would
still see Drake all right let's be
honest gross he's promiscuous can we use
that term for men or is that well you
what what guy that's not nice is also
not promiscuous
that's a contradiction it's the nice
guys that are that are like playing it
straight it's the it's the pookies and
the ray rays those are the promiscuous
but those are the ones that you want
because they're not nice
can I get somebody in between like oh
they want it
oh my gosh
we're living living in in homes is it do
you go like from state to state maybe
like one in one home and you're in
you're in New Hampshire and then another
home you're in Virginia or something
like that are you like an au pair or
kind of What's your deal no or pears
usually come from other countries and
they don't get paid [__] they you know
yeah that's what I grew up with that's
what I grew up with all Paris and that
was really common where the Au pairs
would let me tell you something about
all Paris okay they it was so common for
the odd parents to come in and sleep
with the husbands and they're they're
trying to oh yeah oh yeah they're trying
to get that Visa they're trying to get
that Visa baby so I had I had 20 years
of all pairs okay and I had one au pair
married my uncle another au pair married
my cousin you stay safe fellas
wow listen yeah that's the reverse of
passport Bros right you just bring in
these all pairs to watch these kids
maybe I should just go overseas and find
a husband
that might be the way to go well let's
let's back up how old are you Miley
oh no I'm 23 sir okay so you're you're a
little on the younger side yeah but I'm
experienced I'm still mature whoa whoa
okay
hey let's let's slow down for a second
okay so you're 23 do you want do you
wanna do you want uh are you in a
relationship now do you have a boyfriend
what are you doing no and you don't have
any kids oh God
and do you want to get married one day I
can I do yeah yeah and do you want kids
definitely yeah that's why I chose this
career so I can
make this gotcha now hold up now because
you originally said you've been a nanny
for 10 years and you're 23. so were you
a nanny when you were 13.
well before that just like under the
table yeah
I come from a Hispanic
family it's like standard
the oldest daughter takes care of all
the younger siblings and cousins family
friends and although adults just like
get drunk and go out
gosh you got you okay are you are you
are you a Mexican origin or where uh no
no I feel like I'm being interviewed I
feel like this is Pearl show sorry no
it's my show now this is a takeover
Dominican I'm trying to fix something
anyway
hold on I'm trying to get the camera on
Zoom instead of here a blessings oh
listen I got you I got you okay so you
were working as a nanny under the table
at 13 years old
yeah well before then but like you're
working before you were 13. yeah when
did you start working for pay as a nanny
um
16.
you started working for pay as a nanny
at 16. yeah but I had all those
responsibilities long before them
does that make sense no because yeah it
sounds all messed up like it's okay it's
okay it's about it
[Music]
oh hold on yeah who needs blessing these
days
yes
[Music]
achievement online
oh hello
yay okay now it's oh my gosh I can do
full call-in shows now this is so
exciting I used to be able to do them
but blessing wanted me to upgrade the
software and then I couldn't figure out
how to use it there's like a whole new
learning curve so are you on OBS or what
are you using nothing we direct to
YouTube
direct to YouTube blessing blessing come
up and explain the software please since
you're on overtime come back up I'll
admit you but can you pull up the
comments and the super chats or no no
blessing how do we do that we're the
super chats at guys let's draw some
super chats we're the we're the tens and
the 20s at yeah yeah guys stop being
mean in here like you're making me look
bad in front of lead all his all his
fans are dropping the cash
blessings camera shy he's the only one
allowed to have his camera off salute's
a blessing
well done pill follow my instructions
thank you
he wants to know he wants you to know
that he was in fact a part of me fixing
that
oh okay okay yeah these white people
will take all the credit
no credit no credit I know the blind
people do the work but then they make
all the money and take all the credit uh
yeah I've seen that hey chill out chill
out chill out
with this can you pull up the comments
in the super chats or no
um yeah but then I have to give pill a
tutorial I will show a temporary work
okay okay I can't be looking nice this
is awesome I can't believe you took days
off wow
yeah I'm I'm there six days seven days a
week now I'm working today still pillow
no diesel yeah I'm the worst employer
ever
hello Auntie now you're the best
employer still
let's not say that
how are you doing Tia you doing all
right over there
I'm doing good thank you what do you
think about all this
um I don't know I just
found like I just hit the link right
well I originally had found Pearl I
think on a a jubilee video that someone
else was reacting to and it was a bunch
of feminists like
um like some feminists and some
non-feminists that were they were asking
them questions and I remember thinking
that I couldn't stand Pearl I thought
she just was a woman hater and all this
other stuff
um and then I actually went to a channel
and watched a lot of the videos and it
it was just crazy how
how it just made sense I guess
are you talking about the vice panel
knowledge I don't think I was on Jubilee
oh maybe it was vice yeah it might have
been nice you know it's crazy they were
crazier in person the panel oh my God I
can't imagine it was like three hours
plus of content they added it down to 45
minutes I had some points they edited
out
I had some fun I had some donuts
I'm done that's what's up
where are you guys from
Miley's from the Dominican Republic
apparently
no
um where are you from Miley Las Vegas
okay shout out to Vegas I will be there
uh on the this weekend
all right this weekend that's coming up
for uh nickata's meet up if anybody in
here is going to the nicker meet up
y'all can see me out there so you're
over in uh Vegas uh Miley What's your
deal though because listen I'll be
honest I think tea is from Vegas yeah
Me Oh I thought you said mine Boston
okay y'all have an encore up there in
Boston too that's where I'm staying over
at the uh in Vegas
okay Miley let's add like some people in
the chat are asking some questions and
they're good questions right now let's
listen uh and disrespectfully you know
honestly I'm just gonna call a spade a
spade like you're a cute girl right why
don't you have a man What's your deal
oh
[Music]
um
he said he was gonna marry me and then
he was like oh never mind
he is 36.
36 and you're 23. I met him when I was
20. yeah
13-year uh relationship interesting did
he have any kids
no
no how did you guys meet
bumble
Bumble okay so you like older men then
right because that's a that's a big
that's a big gap right yeah I said that
preference yeah yeah well so your
marriage minded then huh you want to get
married yeah yeah when do you have a
timetable in mind next two years next
year six months oh I don't know I feel
like
I think I ended
[Laughter]
guys I don't have zoom premium
YouTube no no well it was 18 both I was
a cool name or something no I need to
get the premium
I'm sorry guys lead was asking the tough
questions too
oh let me see the super chats enjoy your
new format big fan of yours in Auntie
Jenny's TLA is killing it too I found
Pearl's Channel years ago through
YouTube recommendations
stop being cheap and get the pain
version okay well I well I just tried to
do the zoom today guys
I just try okay should I make another
one so I'm just thinking how long I want
to be on here I was I was 40 minutes
free
stream yard Zoom is awful awful
pay for it well I can't put in my credit
card information on the stream you know
what I mean stop being cheap
spend that YouTube money guys
you can't you can't you don't get rich
by spending all the money you make
I can use Discord
oh I know I am broke broke I'm broke
[Laughter]
that means we've got coins now have you
got a plan
what have you got coins like Bitcoin no
because you're broken now oh yeah yeah
yeah
now wait how do I
um no apparently they're saying Discord
oh I'm not sharing my screen so I can
log in first thing I need to do a
Discord so let me try I'm really not
good at Discord we have one
no but it's a private Discord fine guys
let me get the let me get the premium
Zoom
I used to have this but I didn't use it
enough
[Music]
um
okay premium
products oh there we go
where is this film
okay it's like what
ritual meetings
see
oh my God
business for a year that's not bad for
you I suppose three 250 a year
why are they trying to make me broke
what are you gonna do is just talk for
40 minutes at a time there okay meetings
up to 30 hours per meeting okay well I
think I just see the pro one then 100
attendees
I get a white board included
what's her name I do like whiteboards
yeah I don't think I need the business I
think I can do the 150.
upgrade account
I made one license
foreign
wow
wow okay I just need that
um freaking
blessing is texting me
have you got that's the wrong one what
do you mean it's the wrong one I don't
need Zoom premium
no it's not see blessing agrees he says
250 is expensive it's not if it was 150.
yeah it's 150 blessing
it's like he's not even thinking about
me I just gotta find
um
he's still in there
yeah oh so I'm just catching up
yeah Doug
I want to tell Deb just to come to
England and find a woman right that's it
just come to England and find a woman
yeah it read some of the super chats if
you got a second while I figured this
out
here we go
um
okay
hi DC that's just a normal
he says you were right
it was right about the plan
thanks for looking out don't forget
we're on air yeah I know I've always got
your back I never don't want to take the
pizzeria
no I was saying blessing said you're
ready texted me
um
I'm looking for someone to do reactions
with in London
invalid card number
sweet potato Mama welcome
Philip
Philip omoria
enjoy your new format pill big fan of
yours and Auntie Jenny TLA is killing it
too I found Pearl's Channel years ago if
you're watching YouTube recommendations
from watching reaction videos thank you
very much for fifty dollars
thank you I feel like God doesn't want
me to stream right now I I just checked
the card number is right and it's saying
that the card number is invalid
so
yeah I'm like
I don't know what to tell you guys
God doesn't want me to do these streams
let me look at the chat Pearl reacts
yeah time is
nearly 20 to 1 o'clock in the morning
what now they're talking about the
timeout
it's 1am here
31 am I should probably go to bed what
does dank mean
what dank yeah I don't know what does
snake mean
okay lead
is saying that I'm being cheap
there's some right you can't come on
there and call Pearl dank how small go
away what does dank mean it means like
what did it say on there
dampen code unpleasantly dampened cold
what I'm always important I'm always
warm and pleasant I got nobody's picked
up on that has Mo said Pearl looks dank
we move
I'll carry on
I did just wake up they didn't they
can't come on somebody's Sean call them
don't go away
they really put up there no no insults
for the holes that's up there that's one
of the rules that I see Doug keeps on
putting up no insults no insults you're
gonna come and call it a dank go away go
and look in the mirror yeah well okay
guys I think I'm gonna close out this
live because we're having Tech issues
you know I thought blessing would solve
them for me but you know he's not
America was so he's just a blister he
was asking he was he was you know
he was asking not to work overtime so
much but I think I'll just increase his
hours
I'll just you know
as uh they said that you need a husband
to pay your bills somebody says
um yeah
I'm no arguments there
uh anyways guys I'm gonna be doing these
live tomorrow once I figure out this
equipment I don't use it as much because
it's like confusing to me but I used to
do these all the time so I want to do
them again but like the video on your
way out guys subscribe to the channel
ring that notification Bell